Excellent, ne ich hab nix gesagt, ich hab mir noch schnell was zu trinken geholt unten
in der Küche.
C, S, L, S, M, Twitch, Prime, Sub, Dankeschön, Poggers.
Ich bin heute müde irgendwie, aber ich hab gedacht ich komm trotzdem mal an.
Nein ich bin nicht krank.
STBA42 hat 10 Monat Subscribed, Massive, das ist ja kurz vor, Uplog ploggt nicht mehr
auf Twitch, echt nicht, ja dann müssen die wahrscheinlich für die Listen mal aktualisieren,
gucken wir doch mal, was die da zu schreiben, oh guck mal hier Getting Ads, da seh ich's
doch schon.
Ja die müssen mal wieder aktualisieren und gut ist.
Die müssen das wieder updaten und dann geht's wahrscheinlich, das kommt öfters mal vor.
Ich überleg gerade bekomm ich eigentlich Geld von den Ads, wahrscheinlich ein paar Cent
oder so, ich glaube das macht keinen wirklichen Unterschied.
Was ein Play ist heute, ne, ne wenn ich unter der Woche, wenn ich arbeiten war vorher, da
kann ich nicht mal so wahnsinnig viele Big Brain Geschichten machen.
Ja das kommt als nächstes, ich bann die Leute die nicht mehr über Refling kaufen,
ich seh doch, selbst wenn ich wollt ich seh doch gar nicht mehr über Refling oder was
wie über Refling gekaufte, es ist komplett anonymisiert, ich seh da gar nix, was kennst
du das Programm?
Du meinst das Programm, ja das kenn ich, nein das kenn ich nicht.
Das sagt mir überhaupt nix.
Heute mega wenig Verzöger im Stream, ok, exquisite wahrscheinlich, auch sonst keine
Verzöger, ich hab noch nicht gesehen, da fällt mir gerade ein, ich wollt mir schon seit längerer
Zeit hier mal wieder den Vivaldi Browser angucken, den hatte ich ja lange installiert,
also ich hab den schon mal verwendet als er rausgekommen ist, fand ihn eigentlich ganz
gut, dann hab ich ihn zwischenzeitlich die ganze Zeit installiert gehabt, aber hab ihn
nie verwendet, weiß gar nicht über welcher Version die jetzt sind, weiß auch nicht,
ich find den eigentlich ziemlich gut, aber ich hab den nie verwendet, OPERA Gaming Browser,
da versteh ich wirklich die Existenzberechtigung nicht.
Weil, das haben wir uns mal angeguckt, und außer dass es irgendwelche Themes hat, die
man zünden kann mit RGB, hab ich da nix gefunden, was daran irgendwie sonderlich toll ist.
Was schreiben die denn, was schreiben die denn, achja und die hatten so nen komischen
Taskmanager.
Unify Access, was Zugriffskontrollen starten, ach zeig mal her, das sieht sogar relativ
interessant aus, zeig mal her, ich muss sagen ich mag das Unify Zeug, bis auf die Switche,
die Switche und Router mag ich nicht, ich weiß ich hab einen aber das ist auch ein F-Switch,
hab ich eigentlich zum größten im MikroTag, aber die anderen Unify Sachen find ich eigentlich
ganz gut.
äh Tribulon, ja bin ich noch, also ab dieser Woche wieder, ab dieser Woche, heute war erst
der Home Office Tag, davor war ja bei uns so viel Zeug kaputt, da war ich in der Firma,
ja das ist bei vielen so, hab ich bei einigen gehört, dass es jetzt wieder losgeht.
Unify Edge Max klingt nach nem Router, was Thunderbolt 4 ist released worden, Thunderbolt
4 ist wahrscheinlich das bessere USB 4, Moment, das ist doch die Serie oder, das ist die
Serie, ne so einen hab ich doch, ich hab doch einen, ich hab doch so einen, ich hab doch
so einen Edge Switch, ich hab doch dieses Teil hier, wie gesagt das ist auch ganz gut,
aber ich mag die Unify Geschichten nicht bei Router und Switchen, für Access Points ist
gut, für Kameras ist es gut, was und heute gibt's was, Thunderbolt 4, also soweit ich
weiß sieht das mit Thunderbolt 4 folgendermaßen aus, die haben eigentlich, also Intel, das
ist ja, das ist ja, also Thunderbolt ist ja quasi das Intel USB, so und eigentlich hatte
Intel vor das ganze USB Zeugs dem USB Forum zu übergeben, allerdings hat sich aus meiner
Sicht das USB Forum, also dieses USB Standardisierungsgremium mit USB 4 wirklich, also blöder als die Polizei
erlaubt soll, wie man das ausdrücken soll, angestellt und meine Vermutung ist, dass Intel
jetzt gesagt hat, wisst ihr was, ihr könntet uns mal, wir bringen ne neue, noch ne neue
USB Version raus und so wie sie sein soll, morgen kommt große Ankündigung für Phenis
an Licht, ja hab ich gesehen, das ist dieser Battlefield 3 Remake Mod, da bin ich mal gespannt,
das hab ich gelesen, wie viel Gigabit kann USB 4, ich glaub 40, ich glaub 40 Gigabit
waren das, ja, so ungefähr, also ich glaub es waren 40, allerdings ist der Witz, die
Frage, also das ist ne gute Frage, wo man sieht, wie sehr die das mit dem Standard wieder
verkackt haben, so, weil die Frage kann man eigentlich gar nicht genau beantworten bei
USB 4, denn, und das ist auch eines der Gründe, warum ich glaube, dass Intel jetzt doch mit
nem eigenen USB 4 rauskommt, also im Prinzip ist Thunderbolt 4 mehr oder weniger USB 4,
aber mit, so wie es sein sollte, so, und die Frage, Sascha kann man nicht beantworten,
weil die, das USB, das USB Standard Gremium hat das total verkackt, also man würde ja
eigentlich von ausgehen, dass, dass USB 4 schneller ist als USB 3, das einzige, was
an USB 4 schneller ist als an USB 3, sorry, an USB 3.2, GEN 2x2, man muss ja da, man muss
ja da schon korrekt sein, es gibt einen weiteren Übertragungsmodus, der, glaub ich jetzt,
bis zu 40 Gigabit kann oder so, so, aber, der ist keine Pflicht bei USB 4, das heißt,
du darfst USB 4 Geräte, USB 4 Kabel, USB, also du darfst USB 4 auf dein Produkt schreiben,
wenn du nur die Geschwindigkeit von USB 3.2 unterstützt, das ist halt komplett wir, also
siehste, das, deswegen kann man, deswegen kann man das nicht beantworten mit, also ja,
maximal 40, aber, das heißt nicht, dass es 40 können muss, es können auch nur 20 sein,
also das ist, das ist nicht, ich hab mal irgendwann da mal ein Video zugemacht, wo ich mir ein
bisschen drüber lustig gemacht hab, hier das da, also wenn es dich, wow, what the fuck,
was ist das für eine Seite, warum bin ich denn jetzt hier rausgekommen, Scamas, alter,
was ist das, what the fuck, was, es ist irgendeine Fake, irgendeine YouTube Fake Seite, die meine
Videos embellert hat, also immer irgendeine Werbungseite, so, also da hab ich mich mal
in dem Video drüber ausgelassen, wie das mit USB 4 aussieht und das ist halt einfach
total, total wir, und deswegen glaube ich auch, dass Intel jetzt gesagt hat, sie machen
nochmal Thunderbolt 4, weil die das so verschissen haben im USB Standard Gremium, ich hab das
Gefühl, dass viele Leute, die in diesem USB Standard Gremium sitzen, auch im C++ Gremium
besitzen, dann müssen wir mal gucken, C++ USB Forum, ob das die gleichen Leute drin
sind, member, ja, das müssen wir mal überprüfen, ob da die gleichen Leute drin sind, weil gleich
beschissen ist es an vielen Stellen, das sind bestimmt Überschneidungen und wenn nicht
sollten die sich mal austauschen, ich hab heute wieder ein richtig bescheuertes C++ Feature
entdeckt, mich auch wieder gefragt haben, was ist mit denen los, also C++ ist ja quasi
an vielen Stellen, wo man es nicht erwarten würde undefined, so und ich hab jetzt folgendes
heute gelesen, ich muss mal überlegen, wie beknackt das wieder ist, also das ist so eine
Standardklasse, die in C++ dabei ist, es ist jetzt auch vollkommen egal, was das macht,
zumindest hat diese Klasse aus der Standard Library eine Methode lock, das benutzt man
dafür, dass man, wenn man mehrere verschiedene Threads laufen hat, parallel, mehrere CPU
Kerne parallel Dinger machen, dass man sich nicht in die Quere kommt, dazu verwendet man
das und man kann halt sagen, hier lock und unlock und sprich, solange ich hier lock habe,
muss ich wieder unlock, da kann da kein anderer Task auf dem anderen CPU Kerne drauf zugreifen
und sowas, also sicher ganz sinnvoll, aber das geile ist, C++ hat sich mal wieder, also
die C++ Leute haben sich mal wieder gefragt, ok, warum sollen wir es ordentlich machen,
wenn wir es auch kacke machen können und zwar, wenn man unlock aufruft und der Mutex ist
schon unlockt, dann ist das undefined, bis zu Programm Crash, wo ist das Problem, wenn
ich unlock aufrufe und es ist schon unlockt, dann kann doch einfach gar nichts passieren,
aber nein, nicht so in C++, wenn ich quasi doppelt unlocke, was ja eigentlich keinen
Sinn ergibt, weil es ist ja schon unlockt, dann geht es kaputt im Zweifelsfall, das muss
sein, C++, ja und es gibt natürlich auch keine Methode abzufragen, ob das ganze schon
gelockt ist, ja, es ist wieder so typisch C++, C++ besteht eh zur Hälfte aus undefined
Behaviour irgendwie, ja und hier bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt drauf, um mal ein bisschen vor
und zum nächsten Thema zu springen, ja, easykiller, das Problem, guck hier, ublock, du bist nicht
der einzige, der das Problem hat, das ist wohl gerade Standard, es gibt wohl ein paar Sachen,
was man jetzt machen kann, aber das kommt öfters mal vor, ja, ich hab das auch erst
seit heute oder gestern Abend, aber das kommt öfters mal vor, also das hatte ich schon
ab und zu mal, meistens dauert es ein paar Tage, bis ublock origin den Kram wieder gefixt
hat, ja das ist so lang, so lange halte ich das aus, auf Twitch ist es ja noch nicht so
schlimm, weißt, geht euch das auf YouTube auch so auf den Keks, YouTube hat jetzt ja
angefangen mit, also schon seit vor einem Jahr oder so mit doppelter Werbung, dass immer
zwei Werbeclips kommen und du musst auf YouTube immer skippen, also sprich, wenn es ein Werbeclip
ist, der länger als ein paar Sekunden geht, kann man nach 5 Sekunden skippen, wenn man
allerdings das 5 Sekunden Skippen verpasst, dann darf man den nächsten Clip wieder nicht
skippen, total bescheuert, ja, wie gesagt, also hier bin ich wirklich gespannt drauf,
mal gucken, ob das vielleicht, ob das vielleicht, ja Autos gibt, man kann da vieles machen,
aber das bringt ja auf, zum Beispiel einem iPhone ja nichts, ja, da bin ich echt mal
gespannt drauf, ja, das wäre lustig, wenn die sagen würden, oh ja, wir bringen es nie
raus, also da bin ich gespannt drauf, das werde ich mir morgen angucken, wie gesagt,
das ist ja ein Battlefield 3 Mod, der dafür sorgen will, dass Battlefield 3 wieder spielbar
ist, mal gucken, ob das ganze rauskommt irgendwann noch, ich habe ja die Hoffnung ehrlich gesagt
schon aufgegeben gehabt, die sind ja schon seit 5-6 Jahren in Entwicklung, das ist jetzt
nichts Neues, das ist schon richtig alt, DICE WTF, das ist übrigens ein toller Domain, ja,
da bin ich, ich bin wirklich äußerst gespannt, was da rauskommt, weil sollten die es wirklich
schaffen, dass das wirklich so kommt, wie sie sich das mal gedacht haben, dass man Battlefield
3 quasi mit 100 Tick Custom Server und sowas spielen kann und dass es eventuell sogar Community
Made Maps geben könnte und sowas, dann spiele ich einfach wieder Battlefield 3 und scheiß
auf alle anderen Battlefields, die so rausgekommen sind, das wäre auf jeden Fall sehr nice,
also das ist gut, das benutze ich hier, also das taugt wirklich, also ich finde das gut,
ich finde es besser als New Pipe, allein schon aus dem Grund, weil es die offizielle YouTube
App ist plus gepatcht, da muss man sich nicht umgewöhnen, der einzige Nachteil von YouTube
Vans ist, dass es das nicht im App Store gibt, was ich aber auch verstehe, weil ich glaube,
Google möchte keine gepatchte YouTube App mit App Store verteilen, genau, man kann das
entweder über andere App Stores runterladen oder direkt bei denen, also hier bin ich wirklich
gespannt darauf, da gucken wir mal, was da morgen kommt, also sollten die das wirklich
ankündigen, dann könnte mich das zumindest dezent hypen, Max, zockst du eigentlich noch
ja ab und zu ein bisschen Path of Exile und mal die eine oder andere Singleplayer Sachen
auf Steam oder so, aber es hält sich in Grenzen gerade, liegt aber hauptsächlich daran, weil
es keine Spiele gibt, die mich so richtig mitreißen, mal gucken, also so ein bisschen gut belebte
Battlefield 3 Action hätte ich schon Bock drauf, weil aktuell kannst du Battlefield 3er
höchstens noch auf 1-2 Servern spielen und der eine davon ist 24-7 Demo in Peak Rush,
das kann ich mir auch nur höchstens 4-5 Runden am Stück geben, dann ist irgendwann
auch mal gut, was liegt da, ah Grafikkarten Benchmark, ob das vertrauenswürdig ist, wer
ist das, kennt man den Typ, ok, nee, kenn ich nicht, ok, Grafikkarten Benchmark, nee,
CPU Benchmark, na doch, CPU Benchmark ist nicht Grafikkarten Benchmark, ich hab bei
R7 5800X irgendwie eine Grafikkarte gedacht, das ist CPU Benchmark, was ist denn 5800X,
das ist quasi der Nachfolger vom 3800, gibt es da gar kein 4800, warum gibt es keine 4000,
es ist so schwer bei den Herstellern die Sachen ordentlich zu benennen, erst kommt Windows,
überspringt neuen, dann kommt Firefox und Chrome und überspringt einfach mal 40 Versionen
oder so, Nvidia überspringt auch laufend Dinger, Microsoft weiß gar nicht genau wie man den
Rahmen überhaupt benennen soll, Microsoft benennt die Sachen immer schlecht möglich,
ok zeig mal kurz her, was gibt es denn da für Leaks, was ist denn was, ach hier, das
ist der 1090 und das da oben ist, nee Moment, hä, what, das verwirrt mich jetzt, äh, hä,
Moment, ach nee, ach so, ahja, ja, das ist AMD, ich hab mich verguckt, ich hab irgendwie
dieses muss man vergleichen, also das da oben ist die AMD CPU, das da unten, zeig mal, ich
muss mich ordentlich hinsetzen, und das da unten ist die Intel CPU, also sprich, was
benchmarkt der da, weiß man das, irgendein Game, Crazy 4K, ok, was benchmarkt der denn,
sieht man nicht, ne, weiß jemand was das für eine, äh, was, Ashes of Singularity, ok,
das ist natürlich, ähm, sehr, äh, gut für AMD, weil Ashes of Singularity ist halt, äh,
Multicore-mäßig ziemlich gut, ok, also zeig mal her, Frame Rate, hm, Heavy Batch, Medium
Batch, was auch immer, da sieht man, dass es unter, dass es schwankt, ja, mal ist das
schneller, mal ist das andere schneller, allerdings ist halt die Frage, wie sieht Singlecore-mäßig
aus, das ist jetzt, finde ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig, ich finde das ist jetzt nicht
so wahnsinnig aussagekräftig, mal ist, mal ist Intel hier besser, ich meine, das sieht
auf jeden Fall gut für AMD aus, aber das hat es da vergangen, in den letzten Monaten
ja auch schon, ne, also das, finde ich, ist nicht so wirklich aussagekräftig, oder, ich
meine, hier ist AMD schneller, ach, das ist über alles, oder, ah, ok, verstehe, das ist
über alles, also sprich, die Frame Rate ist ziemlich genau gleich und die CPU ist bei
AMD ein bisschen besser, ja doch, das habe ich schon gesehen, dass das 8 Kerne sind und
dass das 10 Kerne sind, das kann man aber nicht unbedingt jetzt direkt darauf übertragen,
ob der jetzt auch mit 1, 2, 3 CPU-Kernen, also sprich, ob der Singlecore-mäßig so
viel besser ist oder nicht, immer abwarten, aber das wird eh bald vorgestellt, ich glaube,
nächste Woche kann das sein, kann das sein, dass das nächste Woche schon drankommt, AMD
Reveal, das ist nicht mehr lange hin, wann ist das denn, Oktober, ach, am 2., wie am
2. schon, am Freitag ist das, ach, ja, das ist gut, aha, ne, am 8., ok, ok, ok, ok,
am 8., am 8. Oktober, ok, ja, das ist nicht schlecht, gibt es da ein Livestream, was ist
das, kann man sich das, vielleicht können wir uns das zusammen angucken, 28., ne, 8.,
8. Oktober ist Donnerstag, ja, ok, wie viel Uhr weiß man wahrscheinlich noch nicht,
bin mal gespannt, aber es nimmt, es nimmt, also mein nächster Rechner nimmt langsam
Gestalt an, äh, welche CPU benutzt du zur Zeit, ich habe nur ein 8700K, bisschen übertaktet,
übrigens aktuell stimmt gar nicht, nicht mehr übertaktet, hat auch so gereicht, ähm,
und ein 1080Ti und ich will mir schon ein Jahr lang eigentlich einen neuen Rechner kaufen,
aber es lohnt sich halt aktuell noch gar nicht, ja, da bin ich wirklich mal sehr gespannt,
aber ich muss noch kurz chat gucken, aber ich habe nämlich ein paar Sachen übersehen
vorhin, ich müsste das hier auch noch mal einstellen, dass ich Highlights machen kann,
kann man, kann man Highlight, Moment, Moment, Highlight, Eva, warum ist denn das, Chat Appearance
Highlight, äh, Filtering, Highlight Terms, Wobblers, Add, ok, ok, das müssen wir jetzt
mal ausprobieren, Chat, ah, ne, passt, alles klar, dann kann ich nämlich hier durchscrollen,
dass ich nichts übersehe an Fragen, das ist nämlich einfacher, als wenn ich das am zweiten
Bildschirm machen muss, komm, ob du das, äh, also ich finde, das ist mittlerweile ziemlich
überflüssig geworden, dadurch, dass es nicht mehr richtig, ähm, also seit Pihol nicht
mehr richtig, also das ist ein Adblocker, ähm, seitdem das nicht mehr richtig Twitch
und YouTube blocken kann, kann man das, finde ich, nicht mehr gebrauchen, POE-Scheu habe
ich die Liga noch nicht gespielt, ja, wie gesagt, da bin ich äußerst, äußerst gespannt
drauf, ja, ähm, ich mag die Verwaltung von den Sachen über Unify nicht, ich finde so
ein Management Interface, wie das MikroTicker hat, viel besser, aber das ist Geschmackssache,
benutzen kann man beides, übrigens, das wollte ich mir mal angucken, genau, äh, Solo Keys,
das finde ich, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was an denen, was die ausmacht, das ist ja
quasi die Yubi-Key-Geschichte, also so ein Stick zum Keys-Generieren und sowas, äh,
zum Signen und sowas, ist das, aber die Idee finde ich gut, das glaube ich dir nicht,
also ich glaube dir, dass du viele Filter hast, aber dass du es hinbekommen hast, dass
es zuverlässig, ähm, Twitch und YouTube blockt, das glaube ich dir nicht, also doch,
sagen wir so, ich glaube es dir, aber mich würde interessieren, mit wieviel Pflegeaufwand
das verbunden ist, weil gerade YouTube ist ziemlich schwierig damit zu blocken, weil
sie zum größten Teil den Content ausliefern, von den gleichen Domains, die liefern Videos
und Werbung von den gleichen Domains aus, wo es schwierig ist, das zu blocken, weil man
dann auch das Video blockt, ich schwöre, passt schon, ich glaube es dir, achso, ja,
dann ist kein Wunder, wenn du Uplog benutzt, ist logisch, Uplog macht das ganze Jahr,
ähm, wenn du es zum Beispiel schaffst mit einem P-Hole, was auch immer, klingt alles
irgendwie ein bisschen unanständig, ja, wenn du es auch schaffst, dass das auf einem IOS,
in der IOS YouTube App blockt, dann wäre ich beeindruckt, ja, aber das ist ziemlich schwierig
aktuell, das hinzubekommen, äh, genau, ich wollte mir ja kurz das hier mal angucken,
P-Hole blockt doch, nein, macht es nicht, guck mal, also falls, also ich kann ja verstehen,
wenn ihr mir das nicht glaubt, dann hast, also wie gesagt, ich verstehe, wenn ihr mir
das nicht glaubt, aber vielleicht glaubt ihr dem offiziellen FAQ Eintrag auf dem offiziellen
Subreddit von P-Hole, also wenn ihr mir das nicht glaubt, ok, aber vielleicht glaubt
ihr das, dass es kein totaler Mist ist, was ich erzähle, ja, es ist auch relativ logisch,
dass es nicht geht, wenn die wirklich von den gleichen Domains Content und Werbung ausliefern,
dann kann das mit einem DNS Blocker gar nicht gehen, wohingegen das funktioniert ist natürlich
mit sowas hier, wenn man da, wenn man jetzt Uplog Origin, Adplog Plus oder was es da nicht
alles gibt hat, dann ist klar, dass es weg ist, aber wenn man nur einen P-Hole hat, oder
Pi-Hole oder P-Hole oder wie auch immer, dann ist es, wie gesagt, die sagen offiziell,
dann geht es nicht so einfach, oder aber man hat sich mal YouTube Red gekauft und weiß
es nicht mehr, da hat man ja auch keine Werbung, wisst ihr was schön war, YouTube Vans und
der iOS gibt es leider nicht, sonst hätte ich das schon am Start, es gibt ein paar
ähnliche Sachen, aber dafür musst du jailbreaked sein und ich kann mein iPhone nicht jailbreaken,
weil es ja nicht von mir ist, ich habe ja mittlerweile, es sind sogar zwei iPhones von
der Firma, wo ich Arbeit gestellt bekomme und die kann ich nicht jailbreaken, ich glaube,
das käme nicht so gut an, wie funktioniert eigentlich der Werbeblocker Uplog Origins,
also im Detail habe ich mir nicht angeguckt, aber ich vermute mal, dass die den, also den
Content von der Seite analysieren und halt gewisse Sachen eben erkennen, die typisch
sind für Werbung und die halt rausfiltern, der große Vorteil von einem Browser Addon
ist, er kann den Content der Webseite sich angucken, das kann P-Hole nicht, P-Hole kann
DNS Namen blocken, ein Browser Addon sieht den Inhalt der Seite, also sprich das Browser
Addon sieht das hier und kann da Sachen blocken, die typisch für Werbung sind.
Über Indien kostet Premium 160, ok, auf die Idee bin ich jetzt noch nicht gekommen, das
zu machen, YouTube Premium India, das heißt, man sucht sich dann einen VPN, die Idee finde
ich gut, so ein Euro 50 im Monat könnte man dafür mal ausgeben, also sprich, man holt
sich irgendein indisches VPN oder irgendein VPN mit indischer IP, wenn ich das jetzt so
richtig interpretiere und dann bezahle ich da mit, mit was muss ich ihn da drüber bezahlen,
kann ich da ganz normal über Paypal bezahlen oder muss ich dann mit indischen PaySafe
oder so, PaySafe Card, so wie die indischen Scammer, die wollen immer PaySafe und sowas,
hol Don, hol Don, also einer auf Twitch, dem ich wirklich jeden Zuschauer und jeden Subscriber
gönne, ist er hier, gucken wahrscheinlich auch ein paar von euch, den gucke ich mir
echt gerne an zwischendurch, ich habe auch das Gefühl, der existiert so ein bisschen
aus, outside dieser, dieser Twitch Welt, man hört von dem und sieht von dem eigentlich
nichts außer bei sich und, und, das ist, der ist quasi sein eigenes Twitch, so, wie viel
Zuschauer, also dem gönne ich wirklich jeden Zuschauer und alles, das wirklich auch ultra
lustig teilweise, wie er die Scammer verarscht, Jim Browning ist auch gut, äh, bin ich mir
grad nicht sicher welcher das ist, es gibt auch ein paar deutsche Channels, die das
machen, aber Kid Boga mag ich, das ist, man muss sagen, das ist sogar, so blöd es jetzt
klingt, das ist sogar Content, den man, so, so Family Content theoretisch, also das ist
komplett, das ist eigentlich zu 99% oberhalb der Gürtellinie, was jetzt auf Twitch auch
nicht, äh, selbstverständlich ist, ja, ab und zu rastet mal irgendein Scammer aus und
beleidigt ihn ein bisschen, aber das wars, ja, gut, also, das muss ich mir mal angucken,
dann hole ich mir ein YouTube Premium Account über den VPN in Indien, sag ich doch Stripes
007, wie gesagt, P-Haul alleine reicht nicht zum YouTube Adblocken leider, es wäre schön,
wenn, wenn doch, ja, was ich mich frage ist, ob irgendjemand bisher schon einen Werbeblocker
von Foxy Server gebaut hat, weil damit kann man potentiell Mobile Apps besser Adblocken,
die Sache ist nur die, du hast auf einem iPhone, wenn das gut gemacht ist, eigentlich keine
Chance, ne, nein, du hast, du hast eigentlich, also wenn der App-Anbieter auf einer Plattform
wie IOS ist und das richtig macht, hast du eigentlich keine Chance, also, weil auf IOS
ist es ja so, dir gehört das Gerät zwar, aber du kannst natürlich bei weitem nicht
alles machen, also, zum Beispiel ist es so, wenn du auf IOS, also ohne Jailbreak, jetzt
normales IOS, schon mal Edgard getestet, ne, aber es hatte die gleichen Probleme, ähm,
wenn du aus dem IOS App-Store was installierst, da kannst du dir zum Beispiel sagen, es ist
die original Software und sowas, du kannst sie nicht einfach manipulieren und solche
Geschichten, so, und wenn du die original Software auf deinem iPhone hast und, ähm,
die haben das richtig gemacht, also sprich, die checken die Zertifikate vom Ziel und machen
nur Kommunikation über HTTPS, SSL, TLS und, ähm, sie liefern die Werbung über die gleichen
Domains aus, wie der Content kommt und sowas, da kannst du da weder mit nem Proxy dazwischen
großartig was machen, noch mit nem DNS-Adblocker, noch mit sonst was, weil die App kann im Zweifelsfall
auch annäglich im System-Adblocker einfach vorbei gehen und, ähm, du hast unter IOS
eigentlich keine Chance, irgendwas zu machen.
AddGuardHome, das wird das auch nicht können. Das ist auch ein DNS-Adblocker, damit kannst
du die YouTuber auch nicht blocken. Es macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied, also
es ist, wie ich gerade gesagt hab, es ist technisch nicht so ohne weiteres möglich,
unter IOS die YouTube-Ads in der YouTube-App zu blocken. Sofern das YouTube richtig gemacht
hat und nachdem es da um dicke Kohle geht, geh ich mal von aus.
Ja, DNS-Blocker geht, aber DNS-Blocker hilft dir halt bei YouTube nix. Was funktioniert
ist, man kann sich nen Browser verwenden. Also man kann nen Custom-Browser verwenden
mit Adblocker oder man kann, ähm, ich glaub man kann auch global im Safari nen Adblocker
einstellen, das geht, allerdings ist die Bedienung von YouTube über den Browser auf IOS nicht
so schön wie in der App, aber das geht. Das funktioniert. Naja, gut, aber noch, ich wollt
mir jetzt mal kurz hier den Post angucken, was die für neue, was die für neue UniFi-Produkte
haben. Chat, Spam, Cool Cat, 747, 2 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub, Big Brain, Massive
IQ Sub hier. Mal gucken, ob das Highlighten jetzt hier funktioniert.
Ja, genau, das ist übelst cool, der macht das wirklich gut. Oh, jetzt kommen hier die
Big Brain, die Big Brain Tipps hier. Da schreibt er hier, ich hab Netflix-Premium aus der Türkei
mit italienischer Kreditkarte. Na, das ist aber mal hier. Genau so hat man sich das in
der EU vorgestellt, dafür ist das gut. Ne, ich hab nix übersehen. Ich kann grad nicht
im Discord gucken. Ist da was wichtiges? So, genau, ich sollte mal angucken, was die für
neue Sachen haben. Er hat mal einen Chat-Locker überarbeitet. Okay, dann kann ich mir das
ja mal. Okay, Chat, Moment, ich muss euch mal kurz ausmachen, bevor ich Discord anmache,
okay. Nicht, dass Discord im falschen Channel startet, dann bin ich instant gebannt. Da
muss ich aufpassen. Man weiß nie, was die Leute dafür für Sachen gepostet haben. Gerade
der Sebaro ist da immer gut dabei. Ich geh in den Channel gar nicht rein, ich drücke
in den Channel immer nur als gelesen markieren. Okay, alles klar, ich kann euch wieder einschalten.
Okay, was? In Mods hat er was geschrieben. Kann ich in Mods reingucken, ohne dass was
da Geheimes drin ist. Ja, also. Nein, äh, okay. Ja, Sebaro, dann sag nicht, dass ich
den Mods Channel gucken soll. Gut, ich glaub man hat nix gesehen. Ich mach den Mod, ich
mach einfach wieder aus. Liegt Geheimmode, ich mach einfach wieder aus, ich geh raus,
ich geh hier in News und fertig und mach wieder aus. Ich guck mir das von Offstream an. Ja,
ich mach wieder aus. So, also, was haben die dann? Was haben die denn hier Neues für Produkte
am Start? Unify Access, Ubiquities Lösung für Zugriffskontrollen startet. Man hätte
vielleicht nicht Weiß auf Weiß mit Weiß im Hintergrund fotografieren sollen, das ist
übelst schwer zu lesen. Was ist das? Relay? DPS? Rex? Ren? What? Das ist ein Türöffner,
oder? Ein Fernsehtüröffner, oder was ist das? Stadt, ja, lustigerweise. Der Typ, ich hab
keine Ahnung, warum es Stadtprimahafen.de ist. Wirklich kein Pflassen Schimmer, aber
der Typ schreibt relativ gute Blockanträge zu Technik Sachen. Ich hab mich schon öfters
gefragt, warum es Stadtprimahafen.de ist. Ich dachte auch gerade Damage Per Second. Wenn
du mal ein gutes Gameplay sehen willst, sagt der Kuchendienst, empfehle ich dir auf YouTube
ExoGhost. Ist das dein Channel? Bisschen Cross Promotion. Gameplay ist für was denn? Also
was haben die denn? Die in Beta stehen auch die Access-Produkte zum Kauf bereit. Ok, blablabla.
Auch die entsprechenden Info-Seitnisse. Ok, das ist bescheuert, das brauch ich nicht.
Was zu einem Schnäppchenpreis? Nee, das ist viel zu teuer für was, was ich überhaupt
nicht brauche. Auf Unifax ist das PoE. Ja gut, PoEs, das sinnvollste dafür. Was haben
die denn da? Was soll ich damit eigentlich machen? Ok, das ist ein NFC. Irgendso ein
RFID. Warum ist das so teuer? Warum ist ein RFID-Reader von denen so teuer? Ok, da ist
ein Touchscreen und eine Kamera, aber trotzdem, das ist schon. Also sie lassen sich da schon
ganz gut bezahlen, dass es gut ausschaut und sich wohl ganz gut bedienen lässt. Also im
Prinzip ist das eine ziemliche Standardlösung mit einem Kartenleser, einer Karte, guck mal
eine RFID-Karte für 40€. Ist auch schonmal ordentlich. Also das ist echt nicht billig.
Aber wie wollen die das Schloss steuern? Gar nicht, oder? Oder haben die noch das passende
Smartlock dafür? Das kapier ich nicht. Ja gut, man braucht noch die passenden Smartlocks
dafür wahrscheinlich. Aber ihr wisst ja, ich bin absolut kein Smartlock-Fan. Also bei
mir im Haus ist so ziemlich alles in irgendeiner Art und Weise, wenn es sich lohnt, mittlerweile
Smart und IoT und sonst was. Aber Schlüssel und Schlösser ist so eine Sache, da habe
ich mich noch nicht ran gewagt und will ich ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht. Weil dort
wo es was bringen würde, ist zum Beispiel die Haustür. Aber meine Haustür bekommt
kein Smartlock. Das ist glaube ich das letzte was in meinem, also wenn mein ganzes Haus
quasi zur Rakete quasi umgebaut ist, das letzte was übrig bleibt, ist ein poppliches
Schloss an der Tür, was nicht Smart ist. Das gibt es nicht. Also mein Türschloss bleibt
0815 Schloss Schlüssel Oldschool. Hast du schon ein Klo vernetzt mit Smart Home? Ich
habe es versucht. Aber das Klo ist ein Ticken zu alt. Das ist von 2013. Das hat nur so 0815
proprietäre serielle, also 0815 ist serielle Schnittstellen mit irgendwelchen proprietären
Kram drüber. Was ich machen könnte an meinem Klo ist, ich könnte einen ESP32 nehmen mit
Fotoresistor, der erkennt, wann welche LEDs am Klo an und aus gehen und daran könnte
ich mir dann ableiten. Keine Ahnung, ob jemand auf dem Klo ist oder ob ich Spülflüssigkeit
wechseln muss oder sowas in der Richtung. Aber habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht gemacht,
weil ich da den Mehrwert nicht so großartig sehe. Meine Toilette hat schön schnell hier.
Habe ich euch eigentlich, ja habe ich schon erzählt, dass das Video, was ich über mein
Klo gemacht habe, dass das irgendein russischer Channel geklaut hat und sein eigenes Wasserzeichen
drüber gemacht hat. Bdead24 hat das geklaut. Bdead24. Gekommret. Hat mein Video geklaut.
Ja, guck. Youtube. Ja, die haben mein Video geklaut. Ja, Bdead24. Die haben mein Video
geklaut und zwar. Wo ist es denn? Scheiße, wo ist... Hier. Das ist mein Video. Das haben
die geklaut und haben das eigene Wasserzeichen drüber gemacht. Sojumzumz.
Der hat einfach mein deutsches Review von einem Klo genommen und auf seinen russischen
Channel hochgeladen. Und der Chat war übrigens auch schon am Start. Der Chat war schon da.
Strikest du den dafür? Eigentlich ist es mir egal, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Ich weiß nicht,
wo dein Kommentar ist. Vielleicht hast du zu sehr geflamet und hat es gelöscht. War es
nicht? Shadowband, ja. Das ist ein Youtube-Channel für Klo-Reviews. Ja, scheint echt so. Welche
Grafiker hast du in deinem Klo? Hm. Die kann leider nur zwei Farben. Die ist nicht so gut.
Die hat bloß zwei Pixel. Einen großen blauen Pixel und einen großen roten Pixel. Aha, okay.
Ah, okay. Gut zu wissen. Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum man die Domäne genommen hat. Klo-Hacken
im Livestream. Ja, da kann man nichts machen. Also an dem Klo kann man nicht viel machen.
Das ist ein 8000+. So, und wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt, was das für Schnittstellen
hat, weiß ich gar nicht, ob es hier überhaupt ein Bild von gibt. Also, hier auf der Seite
hat man zwei LEDs. Eine blaue und eine rote, die anzeigt, ob es an ist oder ob man Spülflüssigkeit
und sonstige Sachen, Filter nachfüllen muss. Also das könnte man abgreifen, die zwei LEDs.
Hier unten ist die Fernbedienung drin. Hier macht man Spülung an und hier macht man Spülung
den Wasserstrahl, der einem quasi dann den Bobbes absprayt. Den macht man hiermit dann
stärker und schwächer und ich glaube hier unten, hier unten bin ich mir gar nicht sicher,
was die Knöpfe machen. So, und auf der anderen Seite, was man jetzt hier nicht sieht, auf
der anderen Seite gibt es eine Klappe, die kann man aufmachen und da sind serielle Schnittstellen
dahinter. Ich glaube, davon gibt es allerdings kein Bild hier. Übrigens, das war der Reiniger,
weswegen das Klo anfangen konnte zu brennen. Habe ich euch ja schon erzählt.
Ne, man sieht es jetzt nicht. Wie gesagt, auf der anderen Seite, hier, hier genau, auf
der Seite ist noch eine Klappe und da kann man, da sind serielle Schnittstellen drunter,
da kann man nichts abgreifen von. Can it run Crysis? Ja, wenn du es schaffst, dass du da
irgendwie eine Grafikausgabe kriegst, dann kannst du wahrscheinlich zumindest immer Doom
drauf laufen lassen. Ja, das mit dem brennenden Klo war, weil da ist Düsenreinigerflüssigkeit
da drinnen und die hatten irgendeinen Teil, was nicht richtig konstruiert war und dann
ist, wenn es wirklich doof gelaufen ist, ist Düsenreinigerflüssigkeit in die Elektronik
gelaufen und konnte sich dort entzünden. Also sprich, das Klo hätte Feuer fangen können.
Schon Doom auf dem Schwangerschafts, was? Wo?
What? What the fuck. Warum, warum, warum hat der
Schwangerschafts-Test überhaupt einen Controller drinnen? Warum, also wozu braucht der das?
Also ich erkenne da ehrlich gesagt jetzt nicht viel. Warum hat eine Steckdose eine CPU, dass
ins WLAN kommt? Aber warum hat ein Schwangerschafts-Tester, oder viel größere Frage ist, warum hat er
hier ein Internet Explorer Symbol drauf? Warum hat ein Schwangerschafts-Tester einen Micro-Controller
drin? Das verstehe ich nicht. Es gibt Sachen, die werden sich für immer meiner Erkenntnis
entziehen. Was der Stream leckt? Sebaro? Ich glaube nicht. Nö. Keine einzigen Frametrops.
Ich glaube, das ist Telekombat hier wieder. Pains-Champ. Das war wohl fake, der hat einfach
in Tests ein kleines OLED eingebaut. Ja, das klingt mir plausibel, dass das ein Fake war.
Weil mich würde es echt wundern, wenn irgendein Micro-Controller in so einem Schwangerschafts-Test
drin ist. Da sind doch im Endeffekt wahrscheinlich nur irgendwelche, wie nennt man das? So Sachen,
ich weiß nicht wie der Kram heißt. Also das wo es auch so Teststreifen gibt, die einfach
nur irgendwelche Sachen reagieren, auf irgendwelche Sachen reagieren und dann was anzeigen. Also
da muss ja gar kein, das ist einfach was rein chemisches, da brauchst du gar keine
Micro-Controller drin. Wozu? Mikrohänger. Also, ich hab nicht ein Frame verloren anscheinend
dieses, guck mal. Sebaro, ich hab null Frames droppt, also an mir kanns nicht liegen, dass
es ruckelt bei dir. Das ist nicht original, aha. Kann man einen Werbeblocker für ein Netzwerk
machen mit dem Raspberry Pi? Ja, aber wie gesagt Twitch und vor allem YouTube kann
man nicht gut blocken. Weil YouTube sich nicht von DNS-Edblockern austricksen lässt.
Ach guck mal hier. Was ist das denn?
Das ist mein Chatlogger oder? Ach das ist, das ist den Chatlogger den ich mal programmiert
habe, also für meinen Channel, bloß etwas aufgehübscht, ja das ist nice. Was? PpoFat?
Alter, die Domain ist ja geil. PpoF.at, die Österreicher werden sich freuen. PpoFat,
das ist ein super Domain. Und aktualisiert sich das jetzt automatisch? Oder unten, oder
wo muss ich gucken? Ne, also wirklich automatisch aktualisiert sich das nicht, oder? Aber sieht
auf jeden Fall sehr nett aus. Mit was hast du denn das gemacht? Ah, mit Bulma. So sieht
er aus. Ach guck, jetzt hat es ja aktualisiert. Ja, das ist cool. Da kann ich jetzt quasi
immer sehen, ohne dass ich mein eigenes Chat-Tool starten muss, ja Nightbot können wir noch
ignorieren. Ich glaube das habe ich beim anderen auch gemacht. Das ist aber eine coole Sache,
weil da muss ich nicht immer den Chatlogger starten, dass ich sehen kann, ob es noch irgendwelche
offenen Fragen gibt. Das ist sehr praktisch. Wie geht das von der Zeit her? Von links
nach rechts, oder wie hast du das gemacht? Ja, von links nach rechts. Ne, hä? Ah, von
links nach rechts, dann nächste Zeile und dann so. Max, wusstest du mit deinem Job in
der Schweiz das dreifache Verdienst, da du noch dazu in der IT arbeitest? Was? Ja, aber
dazu müsste ich erst mal in der Schweiz arbeiten. Und dazu müsste ich dann, also ich würde
sofort in der Schweiz arbeiten. Allerdings will ich hier nicht weg, ich meine, so ein
paar Leute, die ich kenne, sind hier und ich habe hier ein Haus und alles. Ich meine,
sofern man remote arbeiten könnte, wäre ich da natürlich sofort dabei. Ja, stimmt, mach,
es ist tatsächlich so, mach lieber einen Login davor. Aber es sind Nachrichten an mich,
also da soll sich wirklich keiner beschweren. Denkst du Amazon Luna wird besser? Das kapiere
ich nicht. Warum fängt Amazon, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, Amazon möchte
jetzt auch ins Game Streaming einsteigen. Warum muss jeder jetzt, jeder bisschen größer
jetzt damit anfangen? Playstation hat sowas, Xbox, Microsoft hat sowas, Google hat sowas
jetzt am Start, Amazon hat jetzt auch sowas am Start, die Telekom hat auch sowas am Start,
nur dass es scheiße ist bei der Telekom. Die versuchen wirklich krampfhaft die Leute
dazu zu zwingen diesen, oder was heißt zu zwingen, okay, zu zwingen ist das falsche
Wort, die versuchen krampfhaft die Leute dazu zu drängen Cloud Streaming, also Cloud Gaming
Streaming Services zu verwenden. Aber den Kram will keiner. Leute, wisst ihr wie hoch
der Anteil von Stadia Spielern bei Destiny 2 ist? Von den Gesamt Destiny 2 Spielern,
die hoch, also aktive Destiny 2 Spieler, ja so ungefähr 0,5, ne weltweit, weltweit, so
ungefähr 0,5%, so ungefähr 0,5%, wenn überhaupt, wenn nicht noch weniger. Also da sieht man
wie super erfolgreich die ganze Stadia Geschichte ist, was das angeht. Naja, also, jetzt mal,
ich weiß wir sind hier nicht gerade repräsentativ, hier sind relativ viele Leute technikinteressiert
und haben wahrscheinlich auch einen Rechner. Spielt einer von euch über Stadia? Chat,
benutzt ihr das? Also benutzt ihr das wirklich regelmäßig und quasi hauptsächlich, also
nicht einfach mal, ich hab's mal ausprobiert, sondern so wirklich hauptsächlich zum Spielen
als was anderes. Ausschließlich Grappa. Okay, ja ich mein natürlich, man könnte auch mal
Getter Gaming verwenden, ne also, ich versteh's nicht. Übrigens Leute, ich hab auf der Arbeit
was verkackt, ist mir aufgefallen. Es könnte sein, dass die Leute meinen Stream rausbekommen,
weil ich hab mein Laptop neu aufgebaut, ich hab hier auf GitHub, ich hab hier auf GitHub
meine, hier so ein paar Config-Files von mir. So und da ist irgendwo auch eine Git-Config
und guck mal was in dieser Git-Config drinsteht. Und ich hab aus Versehen in unseren Repos
ein paar Comets gemacht als Wubblors. Ich glaube nicht, dass irgendjemand da was anfangen
kann mit, aber wenn da mal einer danach sucht, ey, wenn du danach suchst, ne, das erste was
du findest, bin natürlich ich, weil der Name ist so unglaublich beknackt, da kommt kein
anderer drauf. Und ich wollt jetzt nicht irgendwelche Rebase-Umschreib-Geschichten machen, dann
funktionieren die Branches nicht von Leuten, die sich in der Zwischenzeit was ausgecheckt
haben und so. Ne. Kannste nicht Git-Play machen? Ja und dann? Dann seh ich, was ich da geändert
hab. Jetzt brauchst du, genau, genau, die logische Antwort hat drauf ist jetzt einfach
den Twitch-Channel umbenennen. Na vielleicht benenn ich mich jetzt auf Twitch doch in Max
FPS um. Max DPS vielleicht, oder was gibt's noch für Abkürzungen in der Richtung? Nein,
nein, nein, ich benenn mich nicht um, Leute. Ich mein, nachdem da keine, nachdem das Comet
nicht gesigned ist und nachdem hier nichts dransteht, könnte ich einfach sagen, irgendjemand
anderes hat das gemacht. Könnte ich einfach sagen, hier, wir haben morgen eine Teamrunde,
jetzt müsste ich morgen auf der Teamrunde sagen, also Leute, achtet doch mal bitte drauf,
dass ihr mit euren richtigen Namen committed. Wer war das denn? Ne. Das merkt eh keiner.
Der Einzige, der es merkt, dem hab ich schon Bescheid gesagt, dass ich das war, hab ich
gesagt, hier solltet ihr nicht wundern, dass Wubblos 2-3 Comets gemacht hat. Ne, es ist
ja auch nicht schlimm. Ja, also selbst wenn es jemand findet, ist es ja nicht so, als
wäre hier irgendwie super secret. Was? Git blame someone else, GitHub. Okay, Moment. Moment,
was machen die da? Ja, aber ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, das funktioniert nicht. Das funktioniert
nicht. Guckt euch, guckt euch die Comet ID an. Guckt euch die Comet ID an. 010. Und
jetzt guckt euch die Comet ID gleich an. Das funktioniert nicht. Guckt, Comet ID ist anders.
Ja, das kann ich auch von Hand, da brauch... Also, mal ganz im Ernst, wer braucht so ein
Tool? Das machst du mit 2 Git Befehlen von Hand. Also das ist ja nur wirklich nicht schwer.
Aber das funktioniert nicht. Also, das kannst du in einem Public Git Repo nicht machen.
Das Problem ist, weil das ein Public Git Repo ist, wo andere Leute auch schon in der
Zwischenzeit einen Stand gepullt haben. Du schreibst dir die History um. Alle Comets
nach dem Comet, was du änderst, bekommen neue ID. Das heißt, du wirst erstmal, was sich
viele Merch-Konflikte provozieren, Git wird rumspacken bei anderen Leuten, wenn die Pull-Request
aufmachen wollen. Wozu? Also, mich stört es jetzt auch nicht, dass da in 2, 3 Comets
irgendwo Wubblos drinstehen. Schaut dein Chef nicht mal... Weiß ich nicht. Auf YouTube,
hat er früher immer geguckt ab und zu, ja. Ist der Name im Hashtag mit drin? Der Name
ist auch im Hashtag mit drin. Also, der Hashtag in Git basiert, soweit ich das aus dem Kopf
zusammenkriege, auf Autor, Uhrzeit, Content und, das ist die hauptsächliche Sache, auf
dem Hasch davor. Das bedeutet nämlich, dass wenn ich das Comet ändere, quasi das 5.
letzte Comet ändere, sich alle darüber auch ändern. Deswegen, Git History ist tatsächlich
read-only, wenn du es so willst. Du kannst sie zwar ändern, aber danach ist die History
anders. Also, eigentlich ist es read-only. Das einzige, was man machen kann, ist, wenn
man alleine dran arbeitet, dann kann man dran rumsauen, wie man will. Und bevor die Sachen
gemercht werden, kann man auch, weil da ist ja noch ein eigener Feature-Pranch, da kann
man auch drin rumsauen, wie man will. Aber danach nicht. Nachdem ich die Comets natürlich
direkt im Master gemacht habe, weil ich habe die Rechte zu, kann ich das jetzt auch nicht
wieder rebasen. Das funktioniert nicht. Außer, dass ich Branches von anderen Leuten kaputt
mache. Ich sage zwar den Leuten immer, sie sollen nicht im Master direkt committen, also
können sie gar nicht. Also, sie haben die Rechte gar nicht, Master zu pushen, sondern
schön Feature-Pranches aufmachen. Aber ich habe die Rechte, im Master zu committen und
im Master den Master zu pushen und zu ändern. Und manchmal, für ganz Kleinigkeiten, mache
ich es direkt im Master. Auch wenn man das laut meiner eigenen Aussage eigentlich nicht
darf. Aber ich sage ja nicht, dass ich es nicht mache, ich sage nur, die anderen sollen
es nicht machen. Ja, so Kleinkram, irgendwelche Change-Log-Einträge mache ich im Master zum
Beispiel. Warum soll ich für Change-Log-Einträge in den Feature-Pranch machen? Das ist total
hängen geblieben. Lohnt sich doch überhaupt nicht. Sowas mache ich direkt im Master. Ach,
stimmt ja. Sorry Leute, Master-Pranch ist ja gar nicht mehr angesagt. Man darf es ja
nicht mehr Master-Pranch nennen, stimmt ja. Es ist Main-Pranch. Noch zack zum Kaboom,
ja, mit dem war ich glaube ich erst vor 3 Wochen oder so essen. All you can eat Sushi
in Frankfurt. Hier, da waren wir. Excellent. All you can eat Poggers. Was, die haben einen
Shop? Wie die haben einen Shop? Online bestellen, ok. All you can eat, haben wir gemacht. Hast
90 Minuten Zeit und kannst rein spachteln, so viele willst. Es ist halt teuer, ja, aber
das ist halt mitten in Frankfurt. All die Dinger sind gut und die haben da nicht nur
so Standard-Zeug, die haben da auch solche Sachen durchlaufen, Garnelen, sonst was, also
ist echt gut. Viel zu teuer, ne, wenn man das ab und zu mal macht. Aber ist schon sehr
nice, ja, was die da am Start haben. Exquisite, exellent. Ja, da müsste ich mal wieder hin.
Ist jetzt zwar erst 3 Wochen her, aber das hat wirklich ziemlich gut geschmeckt. Wenn
ich einen in der Öffentlichkeit erkenne, würdest du auf ihn reagieren, habe ich ja schon. Ich
habe ja schon Leute erkannt. Der Azubi, unser aktueller Azubi hat mich letztens erst exposed
wieder. Auf der Gamescom habe ich auch ein paar erkannt. Andere Azubi hat mich schon
erkannt. The Battlefield Event habe ich da logischerweise auch ein paar erkannt. Klar,
die Chancen sind doch recht gering. Meinst du den Azubi, über den du dich immer lustig
machst? Nein. Der Azubi, über den ich mich immer lustig mache, der ist nicht mehr da.
Das ist auch schon ein paar Jahre her. Du meinst den Azubi, der Git als Shit ausgesprochen
hat, ja. Äh, echt? Elsa, das ist nice. Er sagt, ich komme aus der Schweiz, aber genau
in dem Restaurant, wo er echt richtig da ist. Ist ja auch nicht so weit weg vom Hauptbahnhof.
So, Viertelstunde vielleicht, wenn du langsam läufst. Viertelstunde vom Hauptbahnhof. Wie,
warum das denn? Na gut, in Dev darf auch bei uns keiner pushen. Also ich habe das so eingerichtet.
Also unsere, wie sagt man so schön, in Gitter zu unsere Branching-Strategie ist folgendermaßen,
die Leute können nur in ihren Feature-Branches was machen, allerdings können sie das auf
den Systemen direkt testen und wenn es dann geht, gibt es ein Pull-Request und dann geht
es direkt in Master und dort merge ich das dann je nachdem, wann was dran ist weiter.
Ja, Captain Peng, der Azubi hat wirklich, also unser Spezial-Azubi, der hat wirklich
bleibenden Eindruck hinterlassen, das stimmt schon. Übrigens, wo wir es gerade von hatten,
dass man nicht mal Master-Master-Branche nennen darf, das war ja auf Github so ein großes
Diskussionsthema, aber was noch viel besser ist, die haben jetzt im neuen, also ich würde
mich da jetzt gar nicht so großartig dazu äußern, weil es gibt für und wieder, für
die ganze Geschichte, ich persönlich, aber das ist meine Meinung, kann jeder was anderes
zu denken, finde es ein bisschen übertrieben, dass man da jetzt so komplett drauf haut
und sagt hier, pauschal ist dieser Begriff quasi immer vorbelastet und schlecht und
sonst was. Ja, soll jeder darüber denken was er will, ich finde es ein bisschen übertrieben,
allerdings auf Github ist es noch okay, auf Github ist das noch okay, weil auf Github
stellen sie es den Leuten frei, also du kannst entweder auf Github bei Master-Branche bleiben,
du kannst aber auch auf Main-Branche switchen, also das finde ich ist eine sinnvolle Lösung.
Ja, neue Repos sind jetzt defaultmäßig Main und danach auf Master, das ist okay, aber
nutzt ihr Key Signing teilweise, aber in dem Repo wo ich commit habe nicht, aber was jetzt
richtig geil ist, ist V8 Release Nodes, weiß nicht ob ihr die gesehen habt, die letzten,
die letzten V8 Release Nodes, also V8 ist die JavaScript Engine in Chrome und die unter
Node.js und sowas, also quasi die meistverbreitete JavaScript Engine überhaupt, so und die haben
jetzt Respectful Code eingeführt, du darfst jetzt manche variable Namen nicht mehr verwenden,
also die sind wieder voll, die übertreiben es wieder gänzlich, die übertreiben es wieder
gänzlich bei V8, so und dann haben sie auch ein paar Beispiele drin, was man nicht mehr
sagen darf, also man sollte nicht mehr schreiben Master, man sollte anstattdessen lieber Primary
Controller Leader, ich sag euch mal eins, wenn man alle Sachen jetzt irgendwie so umbenennt,
ich mein Host, das ist so ziemlich die nicht sagenste Variable Namen nach Temp, okay Slave
soll man auch nicht verwenden, sondern Replica, Subordinate Secondary Follower, Device, stellt
euch mal vor man nennt das Device, das ist auch so absolut nichts sagend irgendwie, aber
okay ich mein irgendwie, irgendwie so kommt man da noch hin, vor allem das gilt ja auch
nur für Englisch, wie ist das dann mit Franzosen, die ihre Variablen französisch benennen,
ich sag jetzt nur Franzosen, weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass besonders französische
Programmierer den Hang dazu haben ihre Variablen Namen auf französisch zu nennen.
White List, Allow List, Inclusion List, insane darf man auch nicht mehr sagen, Unexpected,
Catastrophic, Incoherent, okay diese Initiativen, so gut die gemeint sind, also ich gehe wirklich
davon aus, dass das, die meisten Leute die sowas anleihen, die meinen das wirklich schon
so im besten Interesse für alle, also ich unterstell denen gar nichts, dass die da irgendwie
jetzt was durchdrücken wollen oder die meinen das glaube ich wirklich zum größten Teil
nur gut, aber ich erinnere da schon so ein bisschen 1984 Neusprech, so nach dem Motto
es ist keine Blacklist, es ist eine Allowlist, es ist eine Denialist, das ist dann quasi
Doppel plus Primary oder sowas, naja, Respectful Code, ich bin ja immer dafür, dass man normal
mit sich umgeht, aber so erzwungene Maßnahmen führen wahrscheinlich eher zu mehr Problemen
als dass du Leute davon überzeugst, dass manches was sie machen bescheuert ist, bitte sag nicht
dass sie das bei Google benutzen, doch bestimmt benutzen sie das bei Google, also Google ist
ja bekannt für das die bei sowas ganz gut vorne mit dabei sind, die werden das garantiert
benutzen, die machen das nur noch Respectful Code, wisst ihr was ich lustig finde, dass
da so Sachen gesagt, dass da so Sachen gibt wie Respectful Code und sonst was und dass
man möglichst erpicht drauf ist, dass sich keiner ausgegrenzt fühlt und sonst was, was
ich unterm Strich eigentlich sogar ganz gut finde, die Idee dahinter finde ich gar nicht
mal verkehrt, aber auf der anderen Seite, wo keiner, was auch dann voll Respektvoll ist,
dass du die Leute 24 7 ausbeutest, das ist okay, das ist kein Problem, du darfst du darfst
bloß keinen bevorzugen benachteiligen beim ausbeuten, dann wird es kritisch, beutest
du alle gleichermaßen aus und dann ist es okay, das ist auch so eine geile Logik, ich
meine, wenn ihr euch mal anguckt, ich meine jetzt damit nicht unbedingt, dass Apple Smartphones
in China oder so herstellen lässt, aber guckt euch mal Amazon an, wie schwierig sie das
den Leuten machen, irgendwelche Gewerkschaften zu gründen oder Betriebsräte zu gründen
oder sonst was oder gerade auch bei den großen Technik-Läden, sei es jetzt Google oder sonst
was, da arbeiten die Leute ja freiwillig bis zum Umfallen, weil sie sonst Schäpp angeguckt
werden, aber Hauptsache, wenn, also wichtig ist, dass alle gleichermaßen ausgebeutet werden
anscheinend, dann ist es okay, wenn man unter Respektvoll Code vielleicht verstehen würde,
okay, nach vier Stunden mal eine Pause machen und nicht ungefragt bis 21 Uhr in der Firma
bleiben, das wäre mal sinnvoll, Respektvoll Code, das andere kann man auch machen, aber
da hätten wirklich alle was von, aber gerade bei Google, die machen ja auch Videos da drüber
und Microsoft und alle möglichen, die machen ja auch Videos drüber, haben wir uns ja auch
schon ein paar angeguckt, so ein Tag im Leben eines Google Software Entwicklers und sowas
und dann hast du die Leute, die gehen dann um 22 Uhr aus der Firma raus und quasi 5 Meter
um die Ecke und gehen schlafen und am anderen Tag gehen die wieder in die Firma, das wird
nur unterbrochen von, manche gehen dann schon um 21 Uhr und gehen auch mal ins Fitnessstudio
und gehen dann schlafen und kommen morgen früh wieder in die Firma, so stellen die sich
das halt vor, aber da hat keiner Probleme, das ist anscheinend okay, wie heißen diese
Arbeitszeiten, also eigentlich heißt 9 to 6, aber die machen eher 6 to 9, das ist wirklich
der feuchte Traum von Stonksleuten, ne aber das kann es, also mal ehrlich, das kann es
nicht sein, ich weiß, dass wir da auch in Deutschland an vielen Stellen Probleme haben,
dass Leute zu lange arbeiten, gerade bei irgendwelchen Startup Geschichten oder irgendwelchen Läden,
die das nicht so eng sehen, die da auch nichts haben, was das irgendwie kontrolliert, zum
Beispiel gibt es, habe ich schon öfters gehört, gerade im Marketing Umfeld ist es so, wie
gesagt, ich kann es sich allgemein sagen, ich habe es aber schon von ein paar gehört,
dass dort quasi manche Leute ausstechen, damit sie nicht in Konflikt geraten mit irgendwelchen
gesetzlichen Vorgaben, aber dann noch da bleiben, weil es sich nicht gehört vor sagen wir mal
20 Uhr nach Hause zu gehen, also sie sind dann irgendwann um 7 Uhr da, sind dann halt
um, frag mich nicht, keine Ahnung, um 16 Uhr, sind die mit ihrer Arbeit 17 Uhr, keine Ahnung,
sind die mit ihrer Arbeitszeit durch, 16 Uhr, 15 Uhr, und dann stechen die aus und bleiben
noch da, weil es sich halt so gehört, so und das ist halt für ein Arsch.
Von wann bis wann geht eigentlich dein Arbeitstag, also wenn ich auf die Arbeit fahre, dann mache
ich meistens, dann stehe ich meistens 5.45 Uhr auf und fange so um 7 Uhr an in dem Dreh
und gehe 15.30 Uhr wieder heim, so und jetzt, wenn ich Homeoffice mache, ist es natürlich
deutlich besser, da spare ich eine Stunde hin und eine Stunde zurück, dementsprechend
schlafe ich dann bis 7.45 Uhr und arbeite bis 16 Uhr, ne Schwachsinn, ja doch, ich schlafe
bis 7.45 Uhr, ich spare ja 2 Stunden und arbeite quasi dann so bis 16.30 Uhr, so die Zeit
wo ich normalerweise heimkomme, was deutlich angenehmer ist, weil die 2 Stunden, die man
spart und die 2 Stunden, die man länger schlafen kann, sind halt wirklich Gold wert, ne also
7.45 Uhr auf Dauer aufstehen ist schon, das schlaucht schon ein bisschen, aber ich will
auch nicht später anfangen, weil wenn ich später anfange, dann kann ich den Tag gar
nix mehr machen, dann bin ich lieber ein bisschen im Arsch, als dass ich den ganzen Tag gar
nix machen kann, stellt euch mal vor, ich würde normal arbeiten gehen und dann sagen
wir mal dort erst um, keine Ahnung, 8, 9 anfangen, da müsste ich ja bis 19 Uhr oder
18, 19 Uhr da bleiben, so und wann soll ich denn da noch irgendwelche Streams machen oder
sowas, kannst du komplett knicken, deswegen stehe ich 5.45 Uhr auf, fang entweder 6.30
oder 7 Uhr an, je nachdem ob ich laufe vom Südbahnhof oder nicht und dann gehe ich dann
halt 15.30 Uhr wieder heim, dann kann ich noch ein bisschen was machen, 6 Stunden Tag
wäre Pock, also was ich gut finde ist, was die in Norwegen machen, in Norwegen haben
die komplett 4 Tage Arbeitswoche, ich bin mir allerdings nicht sicher, ob es komplett
ganz Norwegen ist oder nur in Teilen, aber teilweise haben sie es auf jeden Fall in Norwegen,
ich habe es mir nicht so gar angeguckt, zumindest ist das schon gang und gäbe in Norwegen und
ich bin der Meinung, dass das so als Basis besser wäre für viele Leute, natürlich besonders
gut wäre das, wenn man sich das einteilen könnte, vielleicht möchte auch einer nur
6 Stunden am Tag arbeiten oder für 5 Tage wie auch immer, wo es halt Probleme gibt ist,
wenn jemand sagt, nein ich brauche jetzt unbedingt Kohle und will halt 5 oder 6 Tage die Woche
10 Stunden am Tag arbeiten, ok, das kann er ja dann machen, aber ich finde das als Basis
nicht verkehrt, weil viele Leute arbeiten wahrscheinlich mehr als, also ich gehe davon
aus, ich kenne dazu jetzt keine Statistik oder sonst was, dass viele Leute unbewusst
mehr arbeiten als sie eigentlich müssten, weil man halt, so nach dem Motto, man arbeitet
halt 5 Tage, 8 Stunden, so ist das halt, ich weiß nicht wie es genau in Norwegen läuft,
ich weiß nur, dass sie 4 Tage Woche haben, also nach dem Motto, man arbeitet halt 5 Tage
die Woche, 8 Stunden am Tag, so ist das halt, dann macht man das so, obwohl man das eigentlich
geldmäßig überhaupt nicht bräuchte, Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel, klar wenn man das braucht
spricht ja nichts dagegen, das war übrigens auch der Grund, warum ich gesagt habe, ich
arbeite jetzt nur noch 4 Tage Woche, also 2, bei mir war es mehr, stimmt gar nicht, war
nicht der einzige Grund, gab mehrere Gründe, dass der erste Grund war, dass ich gesagt
habe, ok ich komme mit meiner Kohle rein von der Arbeit auch mit 4 Tagen gut aus, so das
war das erste, das zweite war, dass ich ja auch noch Einnahmen hatte, damals was YouTube
angeht und jetzt so ein bisschen Twitch habe ich jetzt ja auch noch, Twitch, YouTube, Amazon,
Amazon nicht AdSense, wie heißt das Amazon Partner Programm, theoretisch könnte ich
den kompletten Sellout machen noch mit irgendwelchen Sponsorgeschichten, irgendwelchen Patreon
Accounts, YouTube Subscription, ach was auch immer, also ich könnte deutlich mehr Sellout
machen als ich mache, ich mache ja eigentlich gar kein Sellout, Ray Channel Legends, naja
das ist nicht unbedingt, aber ich könnte deutlich mehr Sellout machen, viel viel mehr Sellout,
gerade irgendeinen Patreon Account, YouTube Subscriptions und sonst was, da würden garantiert
Leute Subscriben, aber ganz ehrlich ich brauche das nicht unbedingt, warum soll ich es machen,
Twitch Bounty, es gibt so viel Sachen, die man machen kann, also ich könnte einen OnlyFans
Account machen, genau, wo ich dann, da kann ich dann laden ich dann meinen Fußzeh hoch
und wahrscheinlich gibt es auch noch Leute, denen das gefällt, das ist das Internet ja,
Snagger, Snagger brauche ich genau, Snagger Sponsorship, ja und da könnte man wie gesagt,
da könnte man total viel machen, aber ich denke mir die Leute sollen ihr Geld lieber
für andere Sachen als für mich ausgeben, ich habe eigentlich eh genug Geld für das
was ich hier so brauche, ich habe mittlerweile, ich habe, ich muss mich unbedingt und ich
weiß, dass ich das schon seit zwei Jahren im Stream immer wieder sage, ich muss mich
unbedingt mal mit sinnvollen Geldanlagemöglichkeiten beschäftigen oder mich zumindest darum kümmern,
dass ich mich irgendwo beraten lasse und nicht bei irgendeinem Stonks Honora Berater, sondern
irgendwas unabhängig oder irgendwie, weil ich habe so viel Kohle einfach nur sinnlos
rumliegen, die einfach nur da ist und nichts macht, das ist auf Dauer auch nicht Sinn
und Zweck der Sache, das Einzige was ich mehr oder weniger investiert habe, ist ich habe
ein paar Leute Geld geliehen, ja und dafür gibt es ein bisschen Zinsen, also mehr Zinsen
als du jetzt so auf der Bank kriegst, aber halt auch nur Leuten wo ich weiß, dass die
lieber Privatinsolvenz anmelden als das nicht zu, oder sag mal so, lieber ihr Haus verkaufen
als das nicht zu bezahlen, ja, Bitconnect kaufen, exakt, das ist, das ist die Lösung,
das ist die, Bitconnect, genau, ich habe ein Video gesehen, das muss ich euch mal zeigen,
ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen, Solar Miner Money, ich finde es nicht mehr, zumindest
hat er das Video gestartet mit, also nach dem Motto, how to turn solar energy in money
und am Ende, hat er dann gezeigt, er hat glaube ich nach einem Tag, nach einem Tag, der hat
sich so einen Miner gekauft und hat ein Solar Panel aufgestellt bei sich im Garten, was
mit Akku zum Zwischenbuffern und so was und er hatte nach einem Tag, er hatte das irgendwie
8 Stunden laufen und hatte nach einem Tag, glaube 0,5 Cent, Dollar Cent, 0,5 Dollar Cent
nach einem Tag Bitcoin, huge, das ist ja, da wirst du ja reich von, also das lohnt sich,
das lohnt sich auf jeden Fall schon mal gar nicht, Stonks ja, aber ziemlich, aber ziemlich
kleine Stonks, 180 im Jahr, ja wenn man davon ausgeht, dass man jeden Tag 8 Stunden Sonne
hat, Texades, muss ich mir mal angucken, sagt mir gar nichts, da ist es billiger, wenn
du den Miner einfach in die Steckdose vom Nachbarn steckst, ja schon, aber das darfst
du ja nicht, kannst du ja dem Nachbarn nicht einfach Geld klauen oder Strom klauen, warum
habe ich das eigentlich nochmal, achja, dieses Schwachsinn Browser, das werde ich im Leben
nicht mehr verwenden, da haben wir uns einmal angeguckt, war übelst sinnlos, als was verdienst
du nochmal Geld, wie meinste das, also wenn du wissen willst, was ich beruflich mache,
mach mal Ausrufezeichen Beruf, da gibt es ein Kommando für und ansonsten verdiene ich Geld
als, na ich möchte das Wort Influencer nicht gebrauchen, weil ich eigentlich keine Leute
Influencer und auf YouTube eh nichts mehr mache, ja also nebenbei verdiene ich noch ein bisschen
Geld halt mit Ads und Reflinks und Twitch Abos und bisschen YouTube Zeug und sowas,
besser AD genau, das ist genau, ja das triffts, Influencer aus 2012, da bin ich auch echt
nicht böse drum, das ganze YouTube Zeug ist, muss man sich mit zu viel dummen nervigen
Leuten rumschlagen, den Strom direkt zu verkaufen würde viel mehr Sinn machen, ja wahrscheinlich
würde das mehr Sinn machen, das stimmt, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, was man aktuell
bekommt dafür, äh von denen habe ich sogar schon ein paar YouTube Videos geguckt, falls
das die sind, an die ich gerade denke, die folgen mir schon mal auf Twitter, ich muss
die anschreiben, sag ich, ah Snagger, wie siehts aus, mach ma Promotion auf Twitch,
ich Snagger time einfach ein paar mal im Stream, so keine Ahnung, einmal, einmal, ich sag einfach
einmal alle, keine Ahnung, Stunde, anderthalb Stunden, sag ich oh Snagger und Snagger mir
irgendwas rein und dann gibts easy money, ne das mach ich nicht, genauso wie ich keine
VPN oder Raid Shadow Legends Werbung mache, so ein Kack, du hast mich influenzt, dass
ich mit C++ und ESP32 schwöre, das Problem daran ist, ich mein das ist cool, dass ich
nicht da influenzt habe, das Problem daran ist, damit kann man kein Geld verdienen, also
nicht, also ich nicht, du vielleicht schon, wenn du was gutes bastelst, ja, aber ich mach
das hier wirklich nicht um Geld zu verdienen, wenn ich das hier echt machen würde um Geld
zu verdienen, dann würde ich öfters promoten, dass man subscriben kann, dass man natürlich
auch mit Amazon Prime umsonst subscriben kann, dass ich irgendeinen Patreon Account hab, einen
OnlyFans Account hab und wo das man auf, was weiß ich, irgendwo noch subben kann auf YouTube
followen auf alle möglichen Sellout Geschichten, was es nicht alles gibt, könnte ich noch machen,
mache ich aber nicht, ist mir zu doof, dann hätte ich auch Stream Donations beispielsweise
eingeschaltet, oh, no limit xo, Stufe 1, Dankeschön, Subscription, ah nee, du hast verschenkt,
Dankeschön für den Sub und zwar wer hat's denn gekriegt, no game, no life hat's gekriegt,
excellent, ja, Java sollte mich, Oracle sollte mich sponsoren, das ist richtig, warum sponsert
mich Oracle eigentlich nicht, ich sag doch nur Gutes über Java, ich hab noch nie schlecht
geredet über Java, genau, Oracle soll mich sponsoren, die haben genug Geld, Leku verschenkt
2, nee ein Abo, ein Abo und zwar an Safer, Dankeschön für den Sub, huge, too smart,
die Adblocker gehen nimmer, ja, seit heute kannst du Twitch nicht mehr, oder seit gestern
Abend kannst du Twitch nicht mehr ordentlich adblocken, aber ich geh davon aus, dass es
nur ein paar Tage dauert, bis die Adblocker wieder funktionieren, ja, so, ich überleg
gerade, gibt's da irgendwas, gibt's da irgendwas, ach ja habt ihr eigentlich gesehen, dass man
jetzt mit WSL 2 xx Forwarding machen kann, dass es da irgendeine Preview Version von
gibt, ich letztens gelesen, nee nee, es gibt jetzt irgendeine Preview Version, dass man
mit WSL 2, dass die irgendeine Preview Version haben, dass man mit WSL 2 jetzt auch grafische
Programme starten kann, das müssen wir mal ausprobieren, nee, keine Ahnung, ich weiß
nicht mal wo ich es gelesen hab, aber das ist auf jeden Fall doof, zumindest die Sachen
die es bisher gab, ich hab das schon mal ausprobiert, früher, du bekommst zwar Linux, also grafische
Linux Anwendung bekommst du damit zwar zum Laufen, aber du hast halt keinerlei 2D, 3D
Beschleunigung oder sonst was, was ist WSL 2, das ist ein Tool von Microsoft, mit dem
du Linux, hauptsächlich Ubuntu, aber es gibt auch ein paar andere Distributionen, direkt
unter Windows laufen lassen kannst, unter der Haube ist es mittlerweile eine Hyper-V-VM,
aber es ist besser in Windows integriert, also du kannst zum Beispiel auch einen Explorer
starten aus der Bash von diesem Linux System dann, ist eigentlich ganz cool gemacht, aber
mir ist immer noch ein echtes Linux lieber, kannst du dann Linux Native Games auf Windows
spielen, nein, also OpenGL und sowas funktioniert damit nicht, die sind aber gerade dabei und
ich hab letztens gelesen, dass es jetzt einen neuen Preview gibt, wo GUI-Anwendungen funktionieren,
aber irgendwie finde ich das jetzt gerade nicht mehr, vielleicht habe ich mich da auch vertan,
ja ja, mir ist klar, dass man das so machen konnte, aber wie gesagt, es gehen damit keine
OpenGL, also du kannst damit beispielsweise keinen SuperTuxKart oder sowas spielen, du
hast auch keine 2D, 3D Beschleunigung oder sowas, das ist übelst für den Arsch gewesen,
deswegen fand ich es ja gut, dass die gesagt haben, sie wollen da was einbauen, direkt
in WSL2, aber ich finde es nicht mehr, ich habe jetzt vor einer Woche was dazu gelesen,
was ist hier vielleicht, nee, WSL, Graphics, irgendwie sowas, gut, das muss ich mir mal
in Ruhe angucken, dann probiere ich das vielleicht mal in einem Stream aus, ob das jetzt gescheit
funktioniert, weil das wäre auf jeden Fall ganz cool, nee, nee, nicht diesen Medium-Artikel,
oder, ich glaube ich habe irgendwo bei Heise was gelesen, Setting Up GUI, nee, nee, oder,
nee, nee, das ist das alte, das habe ich schon ausprobiert, das war kacke, egal, ich suche
mir das mal aus, wir probieren das mal aus, aber wie gesagt, ich finde es gerade nicht,
und ergeblich ist das beschleunigt, das wäre ziemlich cool, wenn das funktioniert, ja,
das habe ich gesehen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es große Vorteile bringt, jetzt für
irgendwie bessere Linux-Unterstützung bei manchen Programmen und sowas, ich glaube es
ist eher ganz lustig, sich mal die Kommentare anzugucken, wie da manche rumgeflammt haben
im Source Code, ob das genauso schlimm ist wie in Team Fortress 2, Hyper-V ist Paynes-Champ,
aber bei WSL2 merkst du ja so gut wie nix von Hyper-V drunter, GTX kann ich dir gar
nichts zu sagen, keine Ahnung, ach wisst ihr was wir mal machen, jetzt, jetzt, komm
wir haben noch, wir haben noch ein bisschen Zeit, Alter, geh fort, wir haben noch ein
bisschen Zeit, mal gucken was es in Frankfurt für beknackte Jobangebote gibt, ok, wir suchen
in 60329, und gucken wir mal, danach können wir noch was anderem gucken, ok, also was
Nürnberg, das ist ein bisschen weiter weg, Operation, Moment, die suchen jedes Mal Leute
und die finden keine, die finden keine Leute, die haben wir jedes Mal drin, was macht eigentlich
Telekom, Moment, Telekom Jobs, die müssen wir auch immer mal abchecken, ja, Jobs Telekom,
nee Telekom Karriere war es, so Deutschland, gucken wir mal, Frankfurt, Frankfurt, Moment,
Tower, die Technik Jobs, kannst du mir nicht merken, hier bei dem, oh ein Splunk, Q-Raider
Engineer, alles klar, ist Splunk nicht dieses Monitoring, dieses, dieses Statistik einsammeln
Gedöns gewesen, für, für, für Anwendungen, die richtig, genau, wir haben, wir haben nicht
die Magenta DNA dafür, Junior Engineer 7, 7 klingt nach irgendeiner Telekom internen
Geschichte, Cyber Security and Defense, Strategic Deal Executive, das sind Jobbezeichnungen,
wo ich mir anhand des Namens noch nicht mal ansatzweise ausmalen kann, was die eigentlich
von einem wollen, Hybrid Cloud, Open Telekom Cloud, was meinen die, wie viele Leute außerhalb
der Telekom sich mit der Open Telekom Cloud so gut auskennen, dass die intern bei der
Telekom als Open Telekom Cloud Spezialist anfangen können, da gibt es doch niemand,
Customer Support Engineer, also im Prinzip Endkundensupport, nur schöner beschrieben,
ohne Ausbildung ist ein Fall Informatiker, okay, die Ausbildung bei der Telekom soll
wirklich ganz okay sein, das unterscheidet sich überhaupt nicht, je nachdem, wo man
da draufklickt, Senior Cloud Service Engineer, yes, Watercar abonniert Twitch Prime, Dankeschön
für den Sub, Exquisite Subscription, was haben sie sonst noch zu bieten, das ist doch
das gleiche, Senior Customer Support Engineer, also auch Endkundensupport, Endkundensupport
ist so wirklich das mit Abstand schlimmste, was man irgendjemand zumuten kann, also Support
an sich ist schon kacke, aber Endkundensupport ist da wirklich komplett vorbei, hat jemand
von euch die Ehre Endkundensupport machen zu dürften zu First Level oder sowas, wobei
First Level macht hier keiner, dafür kennen sich die Leute zu gut aus, okay also, die
Magenta-DNA, was suchen wir denn, was sucht ihr in die Telekom, Young Professional, da ist
der Peno Bernich-Weitz, Düsseldorf, also ihre Aufgabe, also ich muss sagen, die Telekom
Stellenbeschreibung sind oft mal so geschrieben, dass man echt keine Ahnung hat, was die eigentlich
wollen, du musstest mal First Level Verdrehung machen, euer PP-Hernse, wobei, also als Customer
Support Engineer, also sprich Endkundensupport, im Bereich Remote Cloud Services stellst du
und deine Kollegen abstande fram und bla bla bla, Schwerpunkt Open Telekom Cloud, zu deinen
Hauptaufgaben gehören die eigentlich, okay das ist alles, okay Second Level, Systemstörungen,
Cloud-Anbieter, bla bla bla, mehr Informationen, ah yes, oh diese Informationen, die man da
noch dazu bekommt, das ist schon enorm aussagekräftig, okay also was möchten sie haben, du kannst
idealerweise bereits Cloud und oder Server-Zertifizierung, zum Beispiel MCS, also das ist eine Microsoft-Geschichte,
Microsoft-Certified-System-Administration oder irgendwie sowas, Solution-Associate,
okay, LPIC, nee LPCE, ist was anderes, die meinen glaube ich eher LPIC oder, die meinen
nicht LPCI, oder meinen die LPCI, ich glaube die haben sich verschrieben, ich glaube die
meinen LPIC, oder Open Telekom Cloud Practitioner, es gibt, Moment, die haben Zertifizierung,
man kann Zertifizierung für die Telekom Cloud machen, ja warum nicht, okay das ist in Ordnung,
okay Benefits, was gibt's denn, die kann man gleich mal ausblenden wahrscheinlich, was
gibt's denn, Teilzeit möglich, okay, Weiterbildungsangebote soll Standard sein, betriebliche Altersvorsorge
ist okay, Mitarbeiterrabatte, gut, kann gut, schlecht, ist eigentlich vollkommen egal,
Gesundheitsangebote, ja okay, ja, ja gut, okay was wollen sie hier für den Azubi haben,
okay das ist erstmal 0815 bla bla, man soll sich dafür interessieren, alles klar, ist
auch Grundvoraussetzung meiner Meinung nach, was, Stories rund um den Ausbildungsberuf
zum Fachinformatiker, Khaled, aha, erfahre mehr über Khaled, erstmal Kugis, nee, ich
will keinen Telekom Kugis akzeptieren, ähm, die haben ihre Stellenanzeigen besser geschrieben
als das letzte Mal, das letzte Mal waren die voll mit irgendwelchen Bullshitbingo Zeug,
wo du nicht verstanden hast, was die wollen, das kann man, das kann man jetzt mittlerweile
echt lesen und versteht sogar halbwegs, was die wollen, was ist, was ist Englisch B1,
we are all sitting in one boat, da kacke ich wahrscheinlich ab, wenn es was ist, wo man
richtig gut flüssig Englisch reden muss, ich habe immer das Problem, dass ich absolut
keine Übung habe, ich habe das am extremsten auf der Gamescom gemerkt, so der erste Tag
ist übel schwierig und danach gehts, okay die hier sind langweilig, die sind jedesmal
drinne, attraktives Gehaltspaket, okay das ist schonmal gelogen, wenn das da drinne steht,
ähm, weil das schreibt jeder rein, das ist eigentlich, das einzige was das hier aussagt
ist, wir tun so, als bekommst du bei uns mehr als bei anderen, aber in Wirklichkeit versuchen
wir dem weniger zu bezahlen, Beteiliger im Unternehmenserfolg, gut je nachdem was damit
gemeint ist, 37 Stunden pro Woche, gut das ist ja ziemlich, ziemlich normal mittlerweile,
flexible Arbeitszeitmodelle mit Kleid sind auch ziemlich normal, das sollte auch normal
sein, 30 Tage Urlaub, 13 Monatsgelder, das ist okay, 30 Tage Urlaub, es ist, es ist mehr,
ich glaube 26 Tage muss man gesetzlich mindestens bekommen, aber das ist auch ziemlich Standard,
13 Monatsgelder ist ganz gut, so Arbeitgeber, finanzierte Altersvorsorge, Vermögenswirksamkeit,
okay, ja gut, das müsst ihr ja bieten, okay das ist eigentlich, das ist total langweilig,
wo sind denn diese, wo sind denn die geilen Angebote, wo man sich wenigstens ein bisschen
drüber kaputt lachen kann, Radeberg ist das nicht ein Bier, oh, das sieht halt schon mal
hier richtig exquisite Logo aus, ja doch, das ist Bier, deutsche Bierkultur und die brauchen
ein Systembetreuer Cloud Computing Plattform, das finde ich interessant, das ist ein Bier,
das ein Bier, deutsches Bierkultur, ein Cloud Betreuer braucht, ich gucke absichtlich bei
Golem Jobs, weil bei Golem Jobs sind meistens der größte Stuss dabei ist, doch bei, also
eigentlich ist auch 14 das Monatsgehalt relativ normal, bei uns sind es auch 14 Monatsgelder,
aber es ist zumindest schon mal mehr als wir müssten, hier wird es besser, also das hier
ist noch, das hier ist ja noch ziemlich Standard, Blabla, was ich mich immer frage ist, warte
mal der Sound ist gerade ein bisschen laut, wo ist das Sound, was ich mich immer frage,
warum die ganzen Stellenanzeigen immer anfangen mit, wie geil sie sind, alle, alle schreiben
immer, wir sind Marktführer im Bereich XY und unsere Kunden gehören zu den geilsten
Kunden auf der Welt, das ist auch wieder so was, wo ich mir denke, ok, irgendwie wollen
sie wieder zwei Personen in einer haben, sie wollen auf der einen Seite jemand der Technik
Sachen kann, DevOps ist sogar Security und dann wollen sie jemand der Projektmanagement
macht, irgendwie suchen viele Firmen so Hybrid Leute, aber warum sollte man denn, wenn man
sowas hier kann und technisch gut ist, warum um alles in der Welt sollte man Projektmanagement
machen wollen, ok, das ist ja alles normal, das ist, das ist jetzt alles nix, nix besonderes,
so also was muss man denn können, da wird es schon mal interessanter, ok, das ist klar,
Erfahrungen in der Produktion mit Docker, Kubernetes, Native, was möchten die uns damit
sagen, ab wann ist Kubernetes so richtig Native, es darf in keiner vm laufen oder wie, Rancher,
bei welcher Version sind die mittlerweile, sind die überhaupt, sind die doch Part 2,
Version, ne, die sind, hä, ach ne im Moment, Ranch, die wollen nicht Rancher OS, die wollen,
ah stimmt, ok ne die sind Part 2, Longhorn, ich hab keine Ahnung was Longhorn ist, Longhorn
war mal die, der Codename für Windows, Vista, war Longhorn Windows Vista, ja genau, aber
ich hab keine Ahnung was Longhorn ist, diverse Niedungsderivate, Debian Ubuntu, ja das ist
ok, Ubuntu, ok was brauchen wir sonst noch, Ansible Puppet Helm Deployment Helm, Helm
Charts Erstellung, DevOps Integration, Erfahrung unter anderem durch Setup und Betrieb, was
unter anderem, Setup sagt mir gar nix, von GitLab Instanzen, GitLab Runern, ok das ist
in Ordnung, Konfiguration von Skripten, ok, ernsthaft, die kommen mit dem fucking OSI-Modell
hier an, ey das OSI-Modell, wie juckt das OSI-Modell, Kenntnisse von Netzwerkprotokollen
des OSI-Modells, sowie tiefgreifende Parametrisierung von Netzwerkservices, Proxy Reverse, Proxy
DNS, NTP, Loadbalancing, auch im Zusammen, im Zusammengang mit Ingress, das ist quasi
der Eingang sozusagen, tiefgreifende Parametrisierung, meinen die, dass man sich damit auskennt,
dass man das individuell, irgendwie Magic-mäßig, dass man sich halt so gut auskennt, dass man
das ordentlich konfigurieren kann, ok, aber, ey, passt, ja passt irgendwie, warum es jetzt
hier mit dem OSI-Modell ankommt, verstehe ich nicht so ganz, ja in der Abschussprüfung
ist das OSI-Modell sehr begehrt, aber das OSI-Modell an sich ist so ein Ding, ganz
ehrlich, ich hab seit der Ausbildung, seitdem ich mit der Ausbildung fertig bin, das einzige,
wenn wir das OSI-Modell erwähnen, ist eher, um uns über irgendwelche Sachen lustig zu
machen, das ist ok, ja, also das ist jetzt nichts, wo man sagen könnte, das ist falsch
oder so, aber eigentlich redet kein Mensch mehr vom OSI-Modell, ok, versiert der Einsatz
von IP-Tables, oh, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi,
oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi,
also IP-Tables von Hand ist gar nicht so einfach, sag ich euch und HTTPS-Zertifikaten, ich
klugscheiß jetzt nicht, dass das nicht HTTPS-Zertifikate heißt, aber das ist ja auch egal, man weiß,
was Sie meinen, Sie sind pragmatisch und können komplexe Sachen fallen, auch das ok, ja, ok,
was was bieten sie denn als deutschlands größte privatbauer sind sind ok
die fangen an mit wir sind die geilsten und die hören auf mit wir sind die
geilsten excellent so muss man das machen ist die
genau das ist die frage wie auch sonst soft geträumt als das sind gut von
freibier steht da nix sie möchten dazugehören dann freuen wir uns über
ihre bewerbung excellent zeige ich mal her was muss man alles angeben titel vorname
keck mich die autovervollständigung
ja alles klar alles klar gut und die wollen aber ich habe gut dabei gut dabei
ok was haben wir sonst noch denn wo sind wir denn sind wir hier stehen geblieben
ok was haben was haben wir sonst noch
aws architect cloud services senior expert das ist ja wieder hier excellent exquisite
begriffe hier nur das feinste vom fein ist das nicht gut genug front and back
and full stack ok einfach für alles also man merkt schon dass in corona
weniger am start ist also das merkt man als wir vor corona gesucht haben war das
fünf seiten voll als ist es ist schon echt weniger geworden
cloud ist für sie etwas anderes als ein drohen der regenschauer pains camp
richtiger pains camp guck die fangen wieder mit dem gleichen an
einer der führenden anbieter für kunden spezifische frage und bla wir sind die
allergeilst und haben die allerbesten kunden immer das gleiche am anfang
es geht schon gut los es geht schon gut los als agiler enabler
fängt schon gut an als agiler enabler steigern wir die effizienz und
wettbewerbsfähigkeit namhafter unternehmer aus der kehr also du bist
ermöglicher auf gut deutsch
gemeinsam mit unseren kunden gestalten wir die zukunft bla bla bla das erwarten
sie bei uns sie entwickeln cloud native software das ist auch so ein geiles
wort was katsu was katsu angesagt ist und gestalten dabei die umgebung tool
chains und pipelines um anwendung schnell aus zu rollen und zu betreiben
ja okay klar ist klar
okay das ließ sich eigentlich relativ relativ normal hier alles ja das ist
alles alles durchaus legitim unix linux system shell script ein agiles mindset
hohe qualitätsbewusstsein team player qualität und starker kommunikation gut
also für einen agilen enabler sollte das ja alles standard sein wahrscheinlich
kein schenkens kennst du capital ich weiß dass das ein deutscher hip-hop man
ist aber ich habe mir noch nicht von ihm angehört habe ich auch nicht vor so
benefits spannende projekteinsätze bei namhaften kunden vor ort heißt das das
ist für mich schon mal kein benefit das ist eher ätzend also das heißt du
wirst dann irgendwo hingeschickt kannst dich da dem zorn der jeweiligen leute
aussetzen und muss dann da irgendwas machen in der umfangreiche onboarding
und einarbeitungsplanung gut ich würde ich würde mal sagen das ist nicht
unbedingt ein benefit im eigentlichen sinne das sollte im interesse beider
parteien sein dass man ordentlich eingearbeitet wird so attraktive reise
für acht du große nein nein hört mir bloß auf die wollen auch noch leute die
permanent in die da hätte ich schon mal kein bock drauf reiseprojekte
ne ne ne ne das hätte die auch gleich mal schreiben können weil dann hätte ich
gleich gesagt na gut ich will mich ich will mich ja eh nirgendswo bewerben aber
dann steigt da nix nix auf jeden fall nix für mich reiseprämie firmenkreditkarte
reisekostenerstattung ohne die vorkasse naja also also wenn man viele reiseprojekte
hat sollte das ja nur wirklich mal standard sein dass das ordentlich
gehandelt wird ob ich jetzt aus apartments oder aus dem hotel lebe macht
jetzt eigentlich ich will eigentlich ehrlich gesagt daheim leben und nicht
irgendwo verteilt über deutschland und die welt flexile arbeitszeit modelle
langzeit arbeitskonto was ist das denn was ist denn ein langzeit arbeitskonto
ist dass das wo man mehr gearbeitet hat als gesetzlich erlaubt ist und die wollen
einem sagen wenn du länger gearbeitet hast das eigentlich erlaubt ist dann
kommt es auf den extra konto und es verfällt nicht oder wie oder was was
soll das sein
was man sammelstunden kann früher in rennte gehen alter da musste aber
ordentlich draufhauen dass du früher in rennte gehen kannst
kleidzeit durch übernutz von so ist das mit kleidzeit aber nur am rande
gedacht weil ich mein dass ich über stunden über stunden ab nutzen kann es
sollte ja wohl klar sein ok aber als da ok ein buch
oh gut die vorteile schocken mich jetzt nicht zu 100 nicht so richtig
und es geht es geht es geht noch weiter ich habe noch gar nicht alles gesehen
pimp your it budget 250 euro im projahr um ihre hardware auf mit 250 euro kriege
ich nicht mal eine maus und eine tastatur ganze 250 euro
oh gott das ist auch kein benefit firmen feiern gehen wir weg benefit firmen
feiern das ist auch kein vorteil bei uns ich muss das ja immer anonymisiert
erzählen bei uns wurde letztens nach der letzten weihnachtsfeier eine
rausgespissen der hat an der falschen stelle auf dem klo beim falschen
gelästert da muss wohl da muss wohl einer auf dem klo gewesen sein mit
einem vorstandstyp und der muss ihm auf dem klo erzählt haben hier so nach dem
motto ich weiß nicht wie es genau war aber so stelle ich mir vor alter die
neuen it maßnahmen sind totaler müll und danach ist der vorstandsmann zu dem
it vorstandstyp gegangen und hat gefragt warum sind eure it maßnahmen
müll und dann ist der it mensch aus allen wolken gefallen hat den typ
rausgeschmissen das gepetzt hat also man muss auf der weihnachtsfeier sollte man
schon aufpassen was man erzählt ok was haben wir sonst noch special
interest groups
bollen kletter also ich kann ich das ist das ist kein benefit das ist was was
sich normalerweise über die zeit an sich bildet also wenn man sich mit
leuten gut versteht macht man eventuell auch mal außerhalb der firma was aber
ganz ehrlich man arbeitet dort um geld zu verdienen nicht dass man mit den
leuten ganz dicke ist so ne also von den benefits ist jetzt für mich ehrlich
gesagt eigentlich nichts so großartig in den benefit
ok weiter die leut und auf die sind aber super agil die sind schon komplett auf
englisch ne ach man ich ich dachte das ist eine englische stellenanzeige aber
ist es nicht das fängt nur fängt nur besonders
agile an
also making an impact that matters aha also ja impact in your face
audit and assurance ok da wüsste ich schon mal gar nicht was die eigentlich
machen sie überprüfen irgendwas und und was ist das also insurance ist
versicherung was ist was ist denn was ist ein assurance
ok wenn man sich besonders sicher ist alles klar gut risk advisory also
spricht sie beraten leute über irgendwelche riesigen über steuern und
und rechtsfragen ok finanziell und konzert gehts in den
consulting laden irgendwelche consulting duz
den leut an habe ich noch nie gehört
blabla blabla blabla blabla blabla blabla ok also was muss man kann
fahren von sind im bereich klaut architektur und saß das find das hört
sich immer wie eine krankheit an saß und bauen sie zusammen mit den
kolleginnen eine def obs prozess auf aha mit klaut aus der application und
managed services digitalisieren wir die die leut projektarbeit und ok blabla
blabla blabla also eigentlich
also es ist ja gut dass man das schon mal schreibt aber sollte nettes sollte
das nicht eigentlich also sollte sich umgedreht sein dass man ist besonders
dass das default ist und man ist besonders hervorhebt dass dieser job
reisebereitschaft erfordert aber es ist eigentlich klar ich meine wenn es
nun consulting und und beratungsladen ist dann müssen die leute auch unterwegs
sein warum man das allerdings gerade als aws solution architekt klaut services
sein muss senior expert keine ahnung also das ist blar
sie haben praktische erfahrungen der nutze von linux unix shell sowie klaut
deployment modellen auf enterprise level insbesondere public private hybrid ok
da hat irgendein personalmensch da gesessen musste da schreiben und wusste
nicht was er so genau schreibt so wie continues integration deployment zum
beispiel jenkins und so nach jenkins ist auch so so so monka monka es monach es
produkt wobei ich denke jetzt eigentlich also ich persönlich mag jenkins weil man
da sehr viel selbst stricken kann ich machte es ist halt auf java basis das ist
das was es schon wieder nicht so schön macht aber gut das ist ich muss sagen
mit github actions fahre ich eigentlich ganz gut in letzter zeit so für
kleinkram ja die ui ist mega pains camp was die haben 300.000 mitarbeiter machen
40 mehr ich habe von denen noch nie was gehört aber ganz ehrlich ich kenne auch
nicht viele krassen consulting stonks leute
ok da steht ja nur wirklich gar nichts dabei warum man warum man sich
bewerben sollte da steht ja wirklich gar nichts spannendes dabei bewerbungs
hinweise pdf
fairness und transparenz in unsere leitbilder
also irgendwie ist ja da gar nichts drin was mich interessieren würde also
also wahrgenommen ich würde mich da jetzt bewerben wollen überhaupt nichts
was mich irgendwie da anspricht dran so springen moment hier hatten wir doch
gerade schon mal das waren die mit mit cloud ist kein regenschauer jetzt
erzählen sie uns dass springen ist für sie mehr als der sonnenstrahl im
frühling ok da hat hinter diesen ich sags euch hinter diesen sprüchen haben
einen 20 mann team marketing leute ein halbes jahr drüber gebrütet mit
passenden sprints kickoffs vorstandsvorstellungen und allem ich weiß
dass das java framework ist aber das ist das ist ungefähr genauso lustig wie
das cloud kein regenschauer ist was vorher geschrieben haben ok das ist im
prinzip genau das gleiche was die vorher geschrieben nur dass es jetzt um java
geht intellijay ultimate eclips pains jam alter sebaro hier zu übertreibst man
nicht und es ist ja gleich die twitch polizei am start von kathos du kannst
ja deine eigene nachricht durch und du bist mott sie nutzen entwicklung
warum ist das studio code drinne
ein abgeschlossenes blablabla blablabla ok das haben wir uns alle schon
angeguckt das ist ok zumindest zumindest bekommen die java entwickler das gleiche
wahnsinnige 250 euro pimp it projekt drahtzieher gesucht walt ich erst mal
schöne times new roman schrift aber dass das wird kaltern besonders ich
seriös oder so ok was suchen die sie sind teil das scrum teams und fahren
von aha die sind agile hyper agile technische beratung des eigenen und
können hier bleiben
bisher sind die sachen heute eigentlich alle recht recht brauchbar geschrieben
man weiß wenigstens was die wollen
kennnisse von java basier schon wieder java das ganze ja gut ich meine es ist
halt enterprise business reisebereitschaft ok dann ist schon mal vorbei
dann ist schon mal vorbei ok also das bieten wir kostenlose
getränke ok das sind schlecht haben wir auch bei uns gibt es auf den etagen
mehrere so ultra teure kaffeemaschinen die irgendwie frag mich nicht 76
verschiedene arten kaffee machen können und kostenlos wasser also das ist ganz
ok also das finde ich nicht nicht verkehrt weiter mit den coachings
möglichkeiten 30 jahre latest generation hat wir dress code nicht
bei uns das finde ich gut dass sie das schon mal hinschreiben das ist gut zu
wissen dass sie nicht ankommen so nach dem motto jetzt auf einmal anzug anziehen
flache hier archienprojekt einer speerspitze der autoindustrie betreuung
durch ein mentor je nachdem wie die das machen kann es auch nervig sei also
wahl des eigenen team leads ok das natürlich cool wenn man sich seinen
chef aussuchen kann jobrad leasing sprachkurs das klingt doch alles in
allem ganz ok noch mal die haben wir doch gerade schon
ach nee das ist immer noch das gleiche
sind flache hier archien und vorteil kommt auf den laden an eigentlich ist
das wichtigste dass du
wie soll ich das jetzt sagen dass du dass du dass ich die anzahl der leute zu
deppenquote möglichst niedrig ist und ja dann da ist das finde ich schon von
vorteil oder sag mal so dass die anzahl der leute zwischen dir und demjenigen
der was von dir will indirekt nicht sagt er nicht er will was von dir sondern
sagt nur dass irgendwas will dass dort möglichst wenige leute sind die das
verfälschen was auf dem weg passiert und und die möglichst wenig so so
profilierung strang haben und dann geht das und dann geht das auch bestimmt mit
ein bisschen nicht so flachen hier archien aber ich finde es eigentlich ganz angenehm
also bei uns ist das jetzt nicht so super super flach aber flacher als bei
anderen banken und flacher als früher bei uns gewesen ist also bei uns ist es
so ich habe einen team leiter der eigentlich so gut wie nix entscheiden
darf also personal mäßig dann haben wir den abteilungsleiter noch einen direktor
und dann den it ober it mensch also das geht
was haben wir full stack java full stack java entwickler oh nee kein kein java
please es sind gar keine so richtige kackanzeigen diesmal dabei ansonsten
haben wir feature ich habe future engineer gelesen die letzten mal hatten
wir immer so richtige kackanzeigen dabei die dann fünf leute in einem wollten
oder irgendwie sich gegenseitig widersprochen heute ist das eigentlich
alles ganz ok hast du personalverantwortung nein zum glück nicht
und will ich auch nicht mein alter chef hat mich immer beschwätzt so nach dem
motto kennst du schon die karrieremöglichkeiten halbes jahr
später ha ha kennst du schon die neuen karrieremöglichkeiten immer gesagt
nein ich kenne sie mittlerweile ja aber ich will nicht und mittlerweile sind wir
auch ein bisschen mehr in der zukunft angekommen dass man also früher ich bin
ja da jetzt auch schon eine ganze weile bei dem laden früher war es bei uns so
dass man eigentlich nur die möglichkeit hatte mit irgendwelchen stonks
management projektgeschichten dort vorwärts zu kommen wenn man dann karriere
machen wollte mittlerweile sind sie auf den
richter gekommen dass es eigentlich auf der einen seite blöd ist leute die
technisch ziemlich gut sind in rollen zu stecken für die sie nicht gemacht sind
also nur weil du technisch richtig gut bist heißt es nicht dass du nur
ein guter teamleiter oder oder ein guter projektmanager bist eher das gegenteil
sogar aber trotzdem wollen die leute die sich
technisch gut ausgehen ja vielleicht mal was anderes machen oder sich sich
wie soll man sagen hocharbeiten oder oder unter dem strich einfach mehr geld
bekommen weil man an also mehr geld bekommen in anderen positionen und da
sind sie bei uns jetzt soweit dass das ist auch neben diesen management
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten auch solche fachlichen technischen sachen gibt ja
dass du dann zum beispiel ansprechpartner experte wirst in einem thema und so was
also da versuchen sie bei uns ein bisschen mit der zeit zu gehen
welche programmiersprache empfiehlst du für den anfang zum lernen ja früher
habe ich immer gefragt was willst du eigentlich machen aber mittlerweile muss
ich ehrlich sagen nachdem man eh nicht drumherum kommt das beste zum anfang
javascript html css
das ist so die generelle allgemeine ratschlag früher habe ich dann immer
noch gesagt ja willst du windows sachen machen dann guck dir mal ein bisschen
bisschen dort net und paar windows gui geschichten an willst web
entwicklungs sachen machen willst du backendsysteme server mäßig machen aber
man kommt heute eh nicht an frontend sachen vorbei egal wo du bist ein bisschen
html css javascript frontend sachen muss man eh können das schadet nicht und das
gute wenn man mit javascript anfängt ist man sieht was passiert auf der
webseite also sprich man sieht visuell was ansonsten meine persönliche
lieblingssprache ist die scharp und das ist auch eine super einstiegssprache
aber wenn man zumindest ein bisschen den hang dazu hat was visuelles oder
irgendwelche frontend web geschichten zu machen dann kann ich eigentlich jedem nur
raten wirklich mit html css javascript anzufangen weil dann sieht man was
passiert grundlagen kann man da auch lernen und man kommt um frontend sachen
eigentlich nirgends wo man so wirklich drumherum
javascript ist halt bei weitem nicht eine schöne sprache aber jetzt nach zig
versionen haben sie hinbekommen dass es doch ganz angenehm zu verwenden ist im
gegensatz zu c++ die es eigentlich immer nur noch schlimmer machen
warum du kannst du kannst hier musst du nicht musst du nicht du machst du
machst du ich würde auch nicht mit typescript anfangen ich würde wirklich
mit stink normalen html css javascript anfangen mit möglichst wenig
dazwischen weil das stimmt nicht und machst du dir code auf startest den
live server und fängst an oder kannst du da machst du links den editor hin
rechts den browser und es refresht den browser sogar automatisch wenn du was
speicherst das finde ich zum einstieg mittlerweile am besten
unterstützt javascript mit der weiler pkt orientier javascript unterstützt total
viel zeug allerdings manchmal nur halbherzig also ja du kannst du kannst
klassen anlegen in javascript aber das ist irgendwie auch nur halbherzig du
kannst funktionale sachen machen javascript ist auch halbherzig ja und wenn
du ganz viele halbherzige sachen hast da kommt dann irgendwann javascript bei
raus nur dass sie es bei javascript geschafft haben das zu irgendwie einem
halbwegs stimmigen ganzen zu verbinden mit den letzten paar versionen halt wie
gesagt im gegensatz zu c++ was immer nur noch schlimmer wird
übrigens c++ pass mal auf an was denkt ihr an was denkt ihr wenn ihr das hier
lest was was denkt ihr für was steht mem und für was steht fn
memory sagt das im bau nein es ist nicht memory weil es c++ ist und in c++ ist
nichts logisch es steht nicht für memory jeder denkt instinktiv dass es für
memory steht ich denke auch dass es für memory steht aber es steht für member
es steht für member nicht memory es steht für member
es ist halt es ist halt c++
es steht für member
die sind nicht mehr ganz dicht im c++ cremium die sind einfach komplett
pepega im kopf
ja fn steht für function ja das stimmt aber das ist nicht wie kann man sachen
so dermaßen schlecht benennen dass man auf sowas kommt ich mein das gibt
ein cremium was darüber entscheidet da müssen doch ein paar leute mit
hirn drinnen sein
ach ja übrigens wisst ihr wie der vorgänger hieß der vorgänger von mem
von mem fn hieß ist kein willst mem fun so und irgendwann haben sie sich
gedacht ok mem fun mem fun ist zu doof und das ist jetzt dippi dippi catered
seit c++ 11 und die haben mem fun abgeschafft und hätten mem fn haben sie
eingeführt
die sind wirklich komplett von allen guten geistern verlassen was c++
eingeht das ist wirklich komplett lächerlich was die treiben
die saßen abends zusammen ne keppen peng die saßen nicht so abends zusammen
die saßen so abends zusammen so das ist das einzige wie ich mir das erklären
konnte die haben da gesungen wir brauchen einen funktions wir brauchen
neuen standard leiber wir brauchen einen klassen namen dafür wie benennen wir
das ganze denn was macht es denn ok das ist eigentlich nur ein funktionszeiger
ja funktionszeiger
exzellent funktionszeiger auf was auf klassen member ok das heißt wir nennen
es irgendwas mit pointer nein wir nennen es nicht pointer wenn es function wir
nennen es fn wir nennen es mem fun und dann nein nein nein das gab es ja schon
wir nennen es mem fn so genau das ist das einzige wie ich mir vorstellen kann wie
man auf sowas kommt
es ist fail es ist einfach einfach fail aber es ist halt einfach es ist c++ da
ist man das ja schon gewöhnt so was haben wir hier zu bieten beratung
consulting das heißt moment was soll denn das sein berater konsulten für
rechenzentrums infrastrukturen wirtschaftsingenieur wirtschaftsinformatik
oder quer ok was wollen die noch mal genau da check ich schon mal den titel
gar nicht was sie eigentlich haben wollte gut ich bin ja auch nicht in dieser
ansprechen wollen weil ich bin weder konsultant noch wirtschaftsingenieur
wirtschaftsinformatiker sie fühlen sich in der rechenzentrums beratung und
planung wohl die sind mal oldschool rechenzentrums beratung alles schreit
von der cloud und die sagen einfach rechenzentrums beratung ok blabla blabla
blabla überdurchschnittliche vergütung ja dann sag doch mal was ich bin ja
dafür dass es so policy geben müsste bei diesen ganzen jobseiten wer
reinschreibt überdurchschnittliche vergütung muss auch sagen was sache ist
das wäre doch mal was da würden 95 prozent nicht überdurchschnittliche
vergütung hinschreiben
einen neutralen firmenfahrt also ich meine die müssen nicht wirklich zahlen
hinschreiben aber die müssten sich dann zum beispiel auch okay das ist keine
ahnung 20 prozent 15 prozent überlokal im durchschnitt ist oder so das das
würden die nicht macht deswegen bär vorbei einen neutralen firmenfahrzeug
was wäre für dich überdurchschnittlich es kommt auf den job an
also ich würde sagen 100k ist durchaus überdurchschnittlich für so was
in der richtung was ich mache
das wäre schon gut überdurchschnittlich aber das machen die
alle nicht 80k wäre auch noch überdurchschnittlich ja ich habe jetzt
ehrlich gedacht eher an was gedacht wo ich sagen würde ja das ist richtig
richtig gut ordentlich 80k ist auch noch überdurchschnittlich aber da kommt man
schon in den normalen bereich rein
also wir reden natürlich von fünf tage die woche und nicht und nicht da wo ich
arbeite sondern so allgemein wenn man sich mal frankfurt anguckt da ist das da
ist das durchaus im rahmen ja
bei uns nicht bei uns gibt es nicht so viel
gut der einstiegs galt ist natürlich wieder was anderes
wie gesagt ich habe keine ahnung was ich eigentlich genau verdienen würde bei
fünf tage woche ich war ich weiß schlichter greif nicht wir haben es uns
ja letztens mal angeguckt wir hatten uns ja letztens mal den aktuellen tarifvertrag
angeguckt das heißt man konnte sich zumindest das mindeste schon mal
zusammenreimen bei der bei der stufe aus
erfahrungsjahre und und stufe ja und wir letzten sehmal mal angeguckt da
konnte man sich das schon ungefähr zusammen reimen bei uns kommt dann auch
ein bisschen bonus drauf und es kommen 14 jahres geld darauf das heißt dann ist
es schon ein bisschen mehr als in dem vertrag drin steht aber im im rahmen ja
also ich würde sagen bei uns ist bei uns ist das wirklich nicht
überdurchschnittlich was man verdient
kann man die ausbilder als berufserfahrung ansehen so also was
schreiben die hier sonst so blabla wir suchen zum nächsten ein konsult für
das rz umfeld für folgende tätigkeiten beratung kunden
zertifizierungsprozesse nach acht du große ne ne ne ne da habe ich ja gar keinen
plan von kennzahlen ermittlung return of invest damit kann ich auch was
anfangen was tco tcu war das nicht mal so ein siegel auf dem monitor wie
energiesparende ist
u pü sicherer umgang mit office 35 65 da bin ich ja genau der richtige für
office produkte umgang da bin ich richtig gut drin ihr wisst ja ich benutze so
viel office produkte immer ich habe ich habe nicht mehr office in einer office
sache überhaupt installiert ok ne das ist wirklich starke itf das
ließ sich normal das ist zwar absolut nichts für mich
ja was da stand was von firmenwagen ne oder
neben einer und einem neutralen firmenfahrzeug meinen die damit dass es
kein firmenfahrzeug ist wurden wurden aufkleber vom arbeitgeber drauf ist oder
wie oder was was ist neutral
ok eine sache ok wir müssen uns jetzt noch wir müssen jetzt so in der
stellenanzeige angucken die so richtig schlecht ist die hat uns heute noch
gefehlt soft einfach nur software entwickler das klingt schon mal gut
juniore beteiligungs controller ich habe legit keine ahnung was das sein soll
kontrollte die beteiligung oder ist der beteiligt an dem was er controlled
moment haben wir nicht vorher gelernt dass controller eigentlich für master
steht also ist das eigentlich der junior beteiligungs master wenn man nach
respectful code geht das ist dann wird es aber schon kritisch hier wieder
landwirtschaftliche rentenbank ok dass die die aber da sind die sachen meistens
nicht so schlecht die also die die anzeigen sind davon leute geschrieben
sowas schon mal geschrieben senior administrator ich brauche jetzt noch so
richtig schlechte einfach nur leiter ich brauche noch so eine stadt ok so was
sucht da stimmt irgendwas nett sap hanna beratung junior konzer jaja das ist jetzt
jetzt kommen jetzt kommen die richtig guten sachen langsam weiß so was so was
so was suchen die über golern ich brauche so richtig schön schlechte
stellen anzeigen ok was ist das ist ein führender saas anbieter was wie
spricht man das überhaupt aus quillic entwickler
was was ist quillic habe ich schon nie gehört quillic turn your data into
business values faster quillic was ist das keine ahnung ist dann 3000 kents anscheinend wird
klick ausgesprochen ok durch ihr bist du erstelle von klick sens des sports
bestens vertraut nein ich weiß auch nicht mal was es ist was für führende
sows anbieter so was so es so es hört sich an wie was zu fordern best vertraut
und setzt ein wissen im cx das ist komplett komplett chinesisch für mich
was die hier wollen quillic klick klassensation optimal zu managen bei der
entwicklung von loads scripten mit klicksens agiles oh ja jawoll excellent
agiles arbeiten du unterstützt unser team dabei unsere saas anwendung in einem
agilen entwicklungsprozess scrum schnell und sicher an den markt zu bringen ist
alles agile du bist motiviert anspruchsvoll umfeld ein bestes zu geben
du hast erfahrungen mit mit klick load balancer darüber hinaus bringst du der
sql und ms sql sowie in der entwicklung von klick extensions mit html 5 a x
alles klar keller kind twitch prime dankeschön big brain
subscription keller kind du bist hier gut aufgehoben das weiß ich wir sind alles
irgendwie keller kinder
ok ich habe keine ahnung was die wollen aber die anzeige ist ok ich will auch
noch mal so richtig schöne richtig schlechte stellenanzeige sehen so
irgendwas wo man noch mal schön lachen kann und dann gehe ich auf wie sie alle
aktive für attraktive vergütung schreiben ohne mal irgendwas ein bisschen
handfestes ja so also langweilig nächstes senior java webentwickler
ja hab das gelesen leute java und xml also jetzt wird es jetzt wird es
hardcore langsam webbasierte schnitt stellen xml pains champ
erstellen von konzepten und belastbaren aufwandschätzung moment ist man jetzt
man ist java entwickler warum soll ich konzepte und aufwandschätzung
erstellen das ist jetzt ich mein dass man mitarbeitet an konzepten und
aufwandschätzung ist ok aber also erstellen muss man das eigentlich
1998 hat angerufen ok das sieht man schon so ein bisschen aus als suchen
die eigentlich zwei verschiedene leute blablabla java enterprise web services
datenbank modellier ok das ist das klingt sehr sehr klassisch old school
ok das ist aber auch nicht wirklich schlecht die stellenanzeige
ich meine das ist nichts wo ich mich bewerben würde übrigens das finde ich
mal gut dass sie wenigstens dabei schreiben dass sie eine kantine haben
sowas ist für mich tatsächlich ein richtiger pluspunkt
sowas sollten viel mehr schreiben wenn die eine kantine haben eine kantine ist
für mich wirklich ein riesen pluspunkt weil da musst du nicht rausgehen und
bist quasi mal angenommen du hast eine halbe stunde mittagspause und bist
eineinhalb stunden allein schon unterwegs das ding was zu futtern kriegst oder eine
stunde unterwegs das ding was ordentlich zu futtern kriegst also da ist eine
kantine wirklich nicht verkehrt die die schon wieder bundesanstalt für
immobilienaufgaben museenwälderministerien leuchttürme was
hältst du von werkstudenten jobs in der it ist halt notwendig dass man also man
muss das ja glaube ich machen als als student dann irgendwelche praktischen
sachen
moment ist es was ganz was anderes
moment was suchen die
okay die suchen wirklich jemand der alles kann oder ich mein die suchen
jemand der planung veranlasst und koordination durchführung überwachung
von ok und das ganze von kleinen instanthaltung und instanz setzungsmaß
also sprich eine art hausmeister oder sowas zum betrieb von dienst liegen
geschafft mit folgen aufgaben stellungen so und jetzt soll zu
schadensmeldung entgegen nehmen irgendwelche sap einträge machen
rechnung kontrollieren
irgendwelche rechnungswesen dinger machen
okay die so glaube ich vorneweg fünf leute
und was wir endgeld okay da gucke ich ja immer gerne was was was kriegt man mit
e9a tvöd was gibt es denn da so zeige mal her wahrscheinlich nix e9a was ist
das hier gar und berechnen so
okay alles klar war gleich wieder weg
das ist nicht das netto bleiben ist das euer ernst
also was der typ alles machen sollte für das geld wird er wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr aufstehen mein die das wirklich mein die das ernst
okay das war schon eine richtige schrottanzeige wenigstens etwas war aber
die warten aber es geht noch schlechter bin ich mir sicher wir hatten schon
anzeigen hier die waren so dermaßen bescheuert
wie das erst nach sechs jahren wie erst nach sechs jahren
nee egal kfc nee knc ich kfc okay bla okay was suchen die ein juni auch geht
juno konsistenz kann jetzt das schlimmste das macht übrigens unser spezialer zubi
macht das auch also unser ehemaliger spezialer zubi
er ist auch juno konsultant geworden nachdem er festgestellt hat dass technik
nichts für ihn ist
okay also richtig schlechte stellenanzeige waren heute gar nicht
dabei also so richtig ultra schlechte pence champ anzeigen da war jetzt nichts
dabei wo ich gesagt habe mega krass aber der kommt ich das computer center die
gibt es wirklich die heißen so die sind sogar relativ groß und ich frage mich
jedes mal beim namen warum die sich ausgerechnet computer center genannt
haben eine duztkultur dienstwagen möglichkeit zum home office kinder
betreuen back ab kindertagesstätte das ist tatsächlich eine gute sache das
computer computer center
gerade gar nicht so viel müll dabei also nichts nix wo ich jetzt sagen würde
super geil wird voll passen bei mir aber jetzt heute heute waren keine so
richtigen müll stellenanzeigen dabei wurde schon gleich gesehen hast dass es
halt absoluter crap ist ist ja genau den meine ich genau den meine ich
der ist jetzt juniokonsult ja sing kann ich nicht gucken
da müsste ich mich einloggen
okay 22 10 schätzt ins bett ich bin eigentlich viel länger und gewesen als
ich eigentlich geplant hatte ich war ja schon müde als ich den stream
angefangen habe jetzt bin ich sogar fast noch einen ticken wacher als ich
vorher macht's gut vielleicht bis morgen ich bin der
letzter zeit ziemlich ziemlich oft am stream sonn wir sehen uns bis denn ich
habe euch gefallen achts gut zu